the fabric of our world is littered with
strange doorways if you know where to
look for them tears portals
anomalies
all leading to places and planes beyond
human imagining and understanding
and
scp-2317 otherwise known as a door to
another world certainly fits that
description
contained and kept at all times under
the watch of armed guards
scp-2317 appears to be a simple and
unsuspecting wooden door in its frame it
hardly looks like it requires such
extreme round-the-clock security or
needs a strange secretive ritual that
the foundation performs presumably to
keep the door closed
but of course sometimes the most
interesting thing about a closed doorway
isn't where it leads
it's what it keeps out
even by the foundation's already high
standards
the requirements and regulations for
personnel who are assigned to scp-2317
seem oddly specific
psychological testing is standard
practice to work for the foundation
but an additional hurdle that anyone has
to clear before even getting to glimpse
at this unassuming wooden door is having
a score of at least 72 on the milgram
obedience examination
it is also mandatory that personnel
assigned to maintaining it are both
unmarried with no children or next of
kin
as well as an unwavering unquestioning
loyalty to the foundation
pure devotion to its code and objectives
these may seem like strange requirements
after all
scp-2317 is just a door
isn't it
perhaps there's a reason that the
foundation keeps so much of the
information about
scp-2317 buried deep under layers upon
layers of security with only the
overseer council privy to the full
details of its strange nature
knowledge as they say is power but maybe
knowing too much about whatever is
behind that door can prove deadly
still if
scp-2317 is the door to another world an
alternate dimension or parallel reality
it must be safe enough to visit after
all the foundation has been sending
personnel in there on a regular basis
daily in fact
according to the o5 council this is done
as part of a procedure to maintain
active containment of
something lurking beyond that old wooden
door frame
but what could possibly warrant such
constant maintenance and surveillance
in accordance with the foundation's
guidelines all staff are required to
rotate out of observing
scp-2317 after every two months
and spend the following third month in
full psychological counseling before
they are permitted to return to the
containment unit housing the door to
another world
it was after one of these month-long
periods of evaluation that a foundation
guard was informed that his security
clearance has been raised to level three
and that he'd been selected for the duty
of carrying out 220 calabasas he knew
the name instantly
this was the title given to the daily
containment procedure that absolutely
had to be carried out
the guard didn't question these orders
after all he'd been selected precisely
because of his loyalty to the foundation
he did make one request to his
commanding officer however he wanted to
know what had happened to the last guard
that had performed the procedure
didn't make it out of psychological
evaluation
the officer replied
not letting this affect his dedication
the guard was told to prepare for
procedure 220 calabasas
along with a fellow member of foundation
security personnel
the guard was instructed to gather
everything on a strange list
the first was a pre-selected member of
class-d personnel
specifically a convicted murderer
class d refers to disposable class
personnel expendable individuals
recruited by the foundation for the sole
purpose of testing scps
class d's were usually prison inmates
repurposed for scp testing and the one
chosen for 220 calabasas was no
exception serving multiple life
sentences for murders or at least that's
what the guard had been told
a foundation personnel member instructed
him to refer to the class d solely as
the assistant from that point on
next the guard collected a live chicken
an obsidian edge knife a silver
asparagulum and aspersorium to be filled
with 500 ccs of holy water that have
been blessed by a priest of the
abrahamic faith and finally a one
kiloton nuclear device which according
to instructions was only to be detonated
in the unlikely event of a catastrophic
containment failure in other words the
last resort
after following his instructions to the
letter and without question the guard
and his colleague were briefed the
foundation personnel member informed
them that he'd be joining and leading
them in the procedure
the staff member also specified that
henceforth he'd be referred to as the
celebrant until the completion of 220
calabasas the guard was acutely aware of
how specific these instructions were but
trusted in the foundation
knowing that if they wanted this
procedure performed a certain way then
it was in everyone's best interest to
carry out the orders to the letter
but what the celebrant then went on to
explain raised far more questions about
scp-2317
than the nature of procedure 220
calabasas
the class d joining them wasn't actually
a class d
the assistant as they were now referred
to was in reality another foundation
staff member
with a level 4 security clearance
specifically tailored to scp-2317
every member of staff entering through
scp-2317 and taking an active role in 22
calabasas needed to be informed that
this assistant was not to be harmed or
treated as a member of disposable class
fighting back the nagging question of
why the foundation would employ this
subterfuge
the guard along with his fellow security
officer the celebrant and assistant
prepared for their departure through the
door to another world at solar noon
when the sun was highest over scp-2317
solar noon chickens and holy water
this all seemed like an oddly occult
combination for the foundation
as they entered the old wooden door
beyond lay a barren salt plane
stretching out for kilometers in every
direction
this alternate dimension according to
the briefing was designated
scp-2317 prime the guard immediately
noticed a ring of seven pillars directly
ahead of the group as they entered
each of them bearing intricately
detailed engravings unlike anything from
any era of ancient history
procedure 220 calabasas was carried out
quickly but carefully
the guard watching as the celebrant and
assistant were careful not to miss a
step
first the celebrant scattered holy water
into the center of the pillars with the
aspergillum and espersorium
looking down at his feet and keeping a
steady pace as he stepped
counterclockwise around them
the guard watched intently as the
celebrant completed his circuit around
the pillars and turned to the assistant
anointing his head with holy water
seven seals
seven rings
seven thrones for the scarlet king
he said aloud
the assistant with the obsidian blade in
his hand took the chicken and dispatched
it in sacrifice
letting its blood mix with the holy
water
he then repeated the celebrant circuit
in the opposite direction before
stepping into the center of the stone
pillars
blood for the old gods water for the new
king the assistant recited
pouring the remaining mix of blood and
holy water over a patch of salt in the
middle of the seven pillars
even though he knew it wasn't his place
to question the foundation
as the 220 calabasas procedure took
place
the guard couldn't help but wonder what
all this was for
it seems so
ritualistic
like something deeply religious or even
magical he never bought into all that
occult mumbo-jumbo even while working
for the foundation
but he had learned not to question
anything even the strangest and most
inexplicable of sights
little did he know that beneath his feet
was an ancient and unknowable horror
a beast chained in lying in weight
contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars sat an impossibly
large creature
humanoid and obese its body covered
entirely in scales thicker than armor
plating
branch-like horns protruded from its
jawless head pointing up to chains that
hung from the seven pillars above
each one hooked into the entity's back
all but one of the chains was broken a
final withering shackle keeping the
devour of worlds in its underground
prison
ever since 1894 bce when erikshia and
mystics imprisoned it the devourer has
been waiting patiently for its
inevitable freedom
it knows as well as the foundation that
nothing can be done to prevent the final
chain from one day breaking even
procedure 220 calabasas won't keep the
creature contained
it's nothing more than a smoke screen
an act designed to create an illusion of
active containment
and maintain foundation morale until a
permanent solution can be devised to
keep
scp-2317 imprisoned
of course if the guard had known this it
would have also explained the need for a
one kiloton nuclear device as part of
this stage ritual
procedure 220 calabasas had all the
components to trick everyone below the
o5 council
emulating religious and occult rituals
the increased level of security
surrounding the procedure and its
purpose
and telling staff that any failure to
correctly and completely
perform the 220 calabasas procedure will
result in an xk class end of the world
scenario
all these elements work together to
conceal the truth that one day the
devourer will escape and lay waste to
our dimension
knowledge is power and maybe knowing too
much truly is deadly
perhaps if the guard had learned any of
this he'd have understood why his
predecessor never made it out of
psychological evaluation
maybe if he had questioned the purpose
of procedure 220 calabasas he'd have
learned the true nature of scp-2317
and what that doorway kept out
but he was loyal to the foundation
through and through
as the team finished performing 220
calabasas and returned through the
wooden door
the guard took one last glance over his
shoulder at the vast salt plain
the entire dimension was calm
silent
but not peaceful
it was patient
the entity had waited centuries for its
time
and now all it would take was the
breaking of the seventh and final chain
one day
the door was closed behind the guard as
he the celebrant the assistant and his
fellow security officers stepped back
through
their work done and as far as they knew
preventing catastrophe for another day
only the foundation higher-ups the
overseer council are aware of the true
danger posed by scp-2317
and its sole inhabitants
current predictions are that at some
point within the next 30 years the
devourer of worlds will be freed
any and all attempts to repair or
recreate the chains holding it in place
have so far failed
as such the o5 council has elected to
continue providing foundation personnel
with the ignorant hope that procedure
220 calabasas is an effective strategy
for containment as we've said
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed door isn't where it leads
it's what it keeps out
in the case of scp-2317
the unassuming wooden door holds at bay
an ancient creature of untold power
that will one day break free and wreak
havoc in our dimension
nothing the foundation does can prevent
it or keep it contained behind the door
to another world
and only the overseer council knows that
any and all efforts to do so are futile
with all that in mind we can only hope
that the doorway of
scp-2317 stays closed
at least for a little while longer
a veteran worker of the scp foundation
sits at his terminal performing one of
the most critical tasks in the entire
organization creating a file for an as
yet undescribed scp but there's
something terribly wrong
his eyes are glazed over his mouth hangs
open is this a zombie or a train
foundation researcher
what is going on like any large
international organization it takes more
than just the exciting action-filled
jobs to keep the wheels turning at the
scp foundation sure the head researchers
guards mobile task force soldiers and
members of the o5 command get all the
praise but a legion of number crunchers
cleaners and paper pushers are equally
important one such person was archivist
walter bainbridge who had been tasked
with digitizing some of the older
records that the foundation had on file
it was when he was innocently recording
the details on scp-050
that he first came under the strange and
startling effects of
scp-055 but the most peculiar part as
with all incidents of
scp-055's anomalous effects taking hold
is that walter had no idea any of it was
happening in his new digitized filing
system he first took note of scp-053
euclid class also known as the young
girl this anomaly was a seemingly normal
human female child who provoked
homicidal insanity in those directly
exposed to her then scp-054
safe class
a non-aggressive humanoid female made
entirely of as well as biologically and
chemically identical to regular spring
water next
scp-056 euclid class a being that
changes form to suit its environment but
only when all observers lose focus of it
and then scp-057
safe class an underground chamber that
crushes the humans who walk within
it was at this point that walter
received a concerned message from one of
his superiors at site 19 mr kovach the
message praised the thorough
digitization of the other anomalies
records but was confused about why
walter had left out any mention of
scp-055
immediately walter was embarrassed how
could he have forgotten scp-055
that iconic anomaly known for
well he couldn't quite say off the top
of his head but he'd be sure to look
into it a quick trip to the site 19
archive showed him that there was
actually quite a hefty file on the
nature of scp-055
which must have been the result of a
huge number of studies what struck him
as strange was that all the files were
filled out in pen rather than being
typed up like a traditional file the
majority of these nodes were written in
shorthand too
as though they were frantically taken
during the tests themselves on extremely
short notice
there weren't even any redactions walter
made a mental note of what he had seen
put the file back in its proper place
and headed back to his computer terminal
however after riding in an almost
trance-like state he looked back on his
work to see that he had written an entry
on scp-058
a giant evil bovine heart with insect
legs and a scorpion stinger strange
he thought that's when walter got a call
from mr kovach on his foundation issue
phone and he didn't sound happy he'd
given walter direct instructions to go
back and digitize the files on zero five
five and instead he'd been working on
zero five eight what was the meaning of
this
walter was typically an extremely loyal
and diligent employee but the verbal
barrage from his supervisor had him
considering talking back just this once
and hoping it didn't get him demoted to
d-class and thrown into 682's acid bath
for playtime
walter gold picked up some courage and
interrupted mr kovach's rant to ask if
he had any idea what
scp-055 actually was
the line went silent for a moment then
his supervisor spoke again this time
with less confidence
of course i can tell you about scp-055
it's a classic one of the first hundred
how could you forget it's uh
or yeah you know it's i think it's the
one with um
another long pause as mr kovach seemed
to search for the words but instead just
trailed off into silence knowing that
some of the anomalies on file were
dangerous memetic hazards walter was
worried for a moment that he may have
accidentally killed his boss by getting
him to think too hard about
scp-055 he asked if mr kovach was okay
and finally got a reply
i'm sorry i seem to have zoned out for a
second there what were we talking about
again
but this time it was walter who couldn't
answer he had no idea at all what the
two of them were discussing just moments
ago
he felt disoriented and kind of sick
like they'd taken some low-level
amnesics mr kovach told walter to get
back to his filing duties and they'd
speak later walter then checked the
messages he'd received from mr kovach
earlier and there it was plain as day
you missed zero five five go back and
digitize that before proceeding mr k
but walter had never even heard of an
scp-055 if such an anomaly even existed
what was going on here in that moment
walter realized he was dealing with
something much stranger than just a
standard digitization job after all how
could he properly complete his duties if
scp-055
seemed to be impossible to speak write
or even think about unless you were
directly observing it at that moment
walter had to know and ask around the
entirety of site 19 to find the answers
if he had to
sadly for walter he was about to embark
on a much more challenging task than he
could have ever imagined to paraphrase a
supposed quote from socrates all i know
is that i know nothing and that's also
about the extent of the knowledge we
have on scp-055
also known as the anti-meme and the
self-keeping secret what does it look
like
when and how was it obtained by the
foundation what are its anomalous
abilities
is this thing dangerous
we may never know
because the only anomalous ability of
scp-055 that we're aware of is the fact
that nobody is capable of retaining any
information about it it's crucial to
note that whatever zero five five is it
isn't invisible or indescribable
foundation personnel are perfectly
capable of entering its containment
chamber and observing it without
incident but mere minutes after leaving
the chamber any memories of the
particulars of zero five five seem to
spontaneously erase themselves
hence the self-keeping secret but this
didn't deter walter perhaps his greatest
advantage was that he didn't know enough
about the thing he was investigating to
know how futile his mission was he
wanted to know the unknowable and a
pesky issue like impossibility wouldn't
stop him he'd get to whoever he needed
to at site 19 to get the answers he
needed of course most people had no
knowledge of the mysterious anomaly
the common response he got back from his
colleagues was zero five five do we even
have a zero five five while the
realization of sudden memory loss or the
realization of zero five five's
existence has been known to cause
momentary stress
there are no known long-term physical or
mental effects from zero five five's
anomalous abilities it's a fleeting idea
in its purest form like forgetting why
you walked into a room zero five five
could be the most harmless object on the
foundation's roster
or
the most deadly either way
we just don't know
at times walter worried he was going
insane zero five five and everything
related to it was gaslighting him was
zero five five even real the one thing
that proved to him that zero five five
must have existed is that its
containment chamber existed
according to the official records kept
by the foundation on the site 19
containment facilities
zero five five is kept in a five by five
by two point five meter square room
constructed of 50 foot thick cement with
a faraday cage surrounding the cement
walls
the report continues that access is via
a heavy containment door measuring 2 by
2.5 meters constructed on bearings to
ensure door closes and locks
automatically unless held open
deliberately
zero five five cell is one of the few to
have no posted security guards and any
personnel working on other scps in the
area are ordered to remain at least 50
feet from the geometric center of zero
five five cell
where the anomaly itself is kept when he
tried to explore further why the cell
was constructed in this manner he found
that surprise surprise
nobody knew zero five five was an
anomaly whose containment requirements
were so mysterious that it automatically
netted itself a keter class designation
after all
how can you properly contain something
you can't even hope to comprehend there
were plenty of rumors about the true
nature of zero five five
some of the more conspiratorial minds at
site 19 theorized that zero five five
was actually an autonomous or remotely
controlled spy inserted into the site to
observe foundation operations or even
humanity as a whole if you're on the
more paranoid end of the psychological
spectrum this theory makes total sense
an anomaly that's physically impossible
to remember even when writings and
pictures on the subject exist would be a
perfect spy however this was all
ultimately little more than speculation
walter was barely any further along than
when he started there were multiple
points in his investigations where
walter seriously considered giving up
until finally he had a major
breakthrough dr bartholomew hughes and
dr john marachek were two scientists
that had performed extensive research
into zero five five and who walter hoped
might have the answers he sought about
the self-keeping secret
these scientists were the first to
discover the anti-memetic nature of zero
five five performing numerous tests on
d-class personnel to see if it was
possible to create feasible written
records
sketches or any other records or
impressions that could bypass its
anomalous effects
the disorienting memory ruining effects
of zero five five also extend to any
materials concerning zero five five
it seems to be a truly uncrackable code
but dr hughes may have finally found
some cracks in the armor
for starters the fact that we're able to
remember that zero five five is an
anti-mimetic is an ironic exception to
its anti-memetic qualities this
revelation also inspired another
realization from dr hughes
would it be possible to discover more
about zero five five from the process of
deduction rather than the typical
induction in other words could they
possibly learn about zero five five by
figuring out all the things it isn't
rather than what it is
dr marachek designed an experiment with
dr hughes to explore this theory they
designed the experiment around a simple
question is zero five five not spherical
in designing the question to
specifically find out what zero five
five isn't they hoped to subvert the
anomaly's anti-mimetic powers walter was
fascinated by this potential method of
getting answers marachek and hughes
found that while the questioning process
for those exposed was often arduous and
frustrating
they could now definitely say that 055
is not a sphere
it is theoretically possible to discover
the true nature of zero five five by an
almost endless barrage of deductive
questions though whether command would
authorize the resources for such
extensive testing is still an open
question
walter in his desperation begged
marachek and hughes for clearance to vue
055 himself the curiosity had become too
great during a search to just walk away
with the single fact that zero five five
wasn't spherical he needed to see this
thing
and after several weeks of filling out
forms and cutting red tape his wish was
finally granted walter bainbridge was
allowed a private audience with scp-055
the subject of his months-long obsession
outsiders observed that walters spent
just over an hour in the containment
chamber taking photos drawing sketches
writing down notes recording audio logs
and reciting memory mnemonics he was
pulling out every stop to counteract the
anti-memetic effects of the self-keeping
secret he was adamant that he would not
be defeated by his non-spherical nemesis
not after all this time and effort once
his time in the zero five five
containment chamber was over he retired
back to his office to finally digitize
his exhaustive findings so that his
supervisor mr kovach would finally get
off his back walter smiled took a deep
breath and began to type
scp-059 keter class this anomaly is a
radioactive mineral that emits a unique
radiation known as delta radiation
exposure to this radiation has caused
strange fungal growths on the infected
wait
what was this supposed to be about again
oh well it couldn't have been that
important
the esteemed doctor thomas more stead
entered the cell of the anomaly
he'd been warned and even chastised by
his colleagues
but who in the foundation could tell him
what to do
he was the best at what he did
maybe the greatest in the whole history
of the foundation
as he entered the room
scp-049 bit in welcome cordial as always
so polite in fact that you'd never guess
you were talking to a killer
dr morstead knew the truth of what he
was dealing with
but he also believed he could get
through to zero four nine
calm him exercise the devil from him it
was the meeting of two great minds one
of them human one of them part human
part
something that has never been clear
it was to be a battle of wits and like
so many great battles this one would
turn into a massacre before we get to
that fateful meeting there are some
things you should know about the anomaly
known as scp-049
if you saw him in the street the first
thing you think of is playing because
zero 049 always looked the same a man
dressed in black robes with a plague
doctor's mask but this wasn't a costume
that could be taken off in fact it
wasn't a costume at all
it was him the robes had grown out of
him like an exoskeleton
that horrible mask with the pointed nose
wasn't covering his face it was his face
a kind of shell that had seemingly
sprouted from bone the first reports
came during world war ii in a
picturesque town in the south of france
called montevallo people had begun going
missing children disappeared from their
beds in the middle of the night and
weren't seen again adults went to the
market and never returned local
authorities searched high and low they
scoured nearby woods and dragged the
rivers but nothing was found because
what was happening wasn't criminal there
was no clue they could stumble upon or
eyewitness who would break the case
no this was something else something
that the townsfolk could never
understand word spread and that's when a
search and discovery team was sent from
the foundation it was a cold dark night
in january of 1941 when the team found
what they were looking for they walked
through the open door of a small house
located not too far from the grand
chateau de aliciu to find a masked man
sitting next to an open fire and he
wasn't alone the floor around him looked
like it was moving upon closer
inspection the team saw that the floor
was covered with writhing grasping
bodies it's patience as it called them
bienvenue chamois said the thing welcome
to my home
those so-called patients crawled towards
the team intent it seemed to cause harm
the hostiles now known as scp-049-2s
were deemed dangerous and had to be
eliminated a sight it seemed that didn't
bother zero four nine in the slightest
they just sat there occasionally looking
up from writing notes in a leather-bound
book as his patients were gunned down
once the carnage ended it simply closed
its book stood up and allowed itself to
be escorted away and that's the story of
how 049 ended up at the facility
becoming a guest of sorts staying in a
standard secure humanoid containment
cell research sector 002 site 19. the
few that came into contact with 049
remarked that it was a pleasure for them
with its impeccable manners vast
knowledge of medicine and human anatomy
sharp tongue and stinging went they
almost became spellbound listening to it
caught in the throes of its charms until
with the simple touch of its hand it
would drain the light from them that's
why scp-049 was classified as a euclid
that's why armed guards were always
stationed outside itself it's why
doctors took great precautions when in
its presence and it's why dr morstead
should have known better remember when
049 was discovered in france it
willingly went with the team like it was
happy it had been found as if it had
planned its own capture when it arrived
at the facility it didn't act like it
was contained against its will it was
like it was returning home
initial findings as to the biology of
049 were that it didn't require any
sustenance at all not even water it
seemed content to be left alone with its
notebooks it did not object when it was
asked if it could share some of its
notes and gladly handed over its
journals but upon examination it was
discovered that they were written in the
language that no linguist or
cryptologist has so far been able to
translate it's apparent that 049 derives
much satisfaction from seeing so-called
experts struggle over its text unable to
read those notes a long line of doctors
visited 049 in itself each fascinated by
what they beheld it was learned that it
has traveled the globe it speaks many
languages but prefers to speak what it
calls le long de la mor french it asks
for only one thing warm-blooded animals
the facility agreed to supply 049 with
various kinds including rabbits cattle
and even an ape on one occasion just
like with humans it could kill the
animals with a mere touch of its hand
sucking the life right out of them but
that wasn't even the most incredible
part soon those animals would rise again
as if reanimated by 049 they would
become for all intents and purposes the
living dead
and they were hostile after several
unfortunate incidents they were taken
from the cell the moment they arose and
disposed of in the incinerator
this was not to the liking of 049 who
would claim it had cured the animals for
it the world was sick it saw plague and
pestilence everywhere and the meaning of
its existence was to rid the world of
disease
humans it said contained a virus and had
to be cleansed in the first days after
arriving at the facility 049 didn't seem
to pose a threat to humans it was quite
friendly in fact it seemed aware of the
fear it caused in staff and would often
go out of its way to make them feel
comfortable and safe this was a ruse of
course or a canard as 049 like to say it
had no intention to help humans
no
it had come for humans it wasn't trapped
it had set a trap one of the first
people to truly upset 049 was dr raymond
hamm a well-respected physician that had
twice been a contender for the nobel
prize for his more mainstream work what
had confused dr hamm the most was not
049's closed-like exoskeleton or even
his ability to reanimate the dead but
the bag that it used 049 was somehow
able to pull a seemingly endless supply
of surgical tools from that bag
sometimes it would even pull out objects
that were somehow larger than the bag
itself it was as if the bag connected to
somewhere else and that's what dr ham
wanted to talk about on that fateful day
with 049 on one side of the cell and dr
ham on the other he asked how is it that
you can produce a great quantity of
tools from that bag i've observed you
and it seems to me that you are doing
the impossible dear doctor
replied049 the scourge the great dying
cannot be fought with a handful of toys
my bag is merely the product of my
imagination it gives me what i require
you dear sir it seems are limited by
your imagination it stopped for a second
or two and stared at dr ham i detect you
are unwell it said in a voice not as
amiable as before it's just a cold said
the doctor ah
just the cold if you had seen what i
have seen you would not utter such
insulting words dr ham pulled out some
papers from a briefcase and approached
049 holding them close enough so it
could read them you see said dr ham
pointing to the results on the paper
those animals you say you cured they
were not diseased
they were perfectly healthy before they
died and your so-called kiera it turned
them into something quite terrible we
found that if they were left alone they
began to eat each other and then
themselves zero four nine did not
respond and after a brief pause said
only a good day to your doctor please
close the door on your way out you
should get some lists
ham refused to go and instead turn the
conversation to this real interest the
bag demanding that 049 let him see
inside of it very well doctor 049 said
in private 049 began to pull a series of
long metal poles out of its bag followed
by a rolled up curtain that it hung
between them creating a kind of medical
tent around dr ham it seemed to stare
for just a moment into the observation
camera outside of itself before whipping
the curtains shut dr ham was discovered
three hours later crawling around the
floor of zero four nine's cell now
another mindless undead when he was
retrieved by security 049 didn't even
look up from his notebook dr ham didn't
get the incinerator treatment but he did
receive a fatal dose of drugs a mercy a
removal team was sent to 049 cell but it
had said there was no need for special
extraction techniques it would go
willingly wherever they wanted to go it
was not it said an enemy of the people
the hippocratic oath forbids me to hurt
a human being it said while walking to
the interrogation center my only desire
is to offer you my services and
expertise
the floors and walls of the
interrogation center room were painted a
bright white even the table was white
which contrasted with 049 a mass of
black sitting in the middle of the room
during the interrogation it refused to
admit or even accept that it had killed
dr ham i cured him i removed the
pestilence from his body it said it was
later asked if it regretted its actions
to which it replied well good sir one
always regrets the loss of a colleague
for any reason but i stand by my actions
the pestilence must be abated before it
is too late every two weeks from that
point zero four nine was given animals
the scientists at the facility observed
it time and again touching the animals
killing them before producing a saw or
scalpel and opening them up organs would
be carefully removed with perfect
precision it was astounding to even
train surgeons just how talented 049 was
i require a close relative of yours said
049 one day to a young doctor who
expressed shock that it was asked for
one of the doctor's family members i
mean a great eight said zero four nine
not your dear aunt there were several
instances of zero four nine displaying a
crude sense of humor staff would almost
forget that the thing that they were
talking to wasn't human almost and it
was dr thomas morestad that had supplied
the great apes orangutans in fact that
had been rescued from the rainforests of
borneo only to be taken to zero four
nine south then one day something
changed
zero four nine told dr morristed that
its work was done that it accomplished
what it had wanted to do and could
someone remove the cured animal from
itself i think you'd find that it's
quite the work of art a triumph 049 said
through the intercom when the removal
team entered the cell they found the
orangutan or what was left of it it was
lying in the corner of the cell the top
of its skull had been removed leaving
its brain exposed on its face was the
expression of relaxation and from its
mouth it issued very soft squeaks like
that of an infant zero for nine said
tell dr morristed that its rage
mechanism no longer exists i've removed
the amygdala and made some changes to
the hypothalamus and limbic system it is
cured and
quite harmless the next day dr morstead
announced that he wanted to visit 049
cell himself after which he heard a
course of disapproval from his
colleagues
all telling him that 049 was now too
dangerous dr ham was sick replied
morested and 049 has assured us that he
would never take another human life he's
never lied to us and i'm going to take
him at his word
it appeared that 049 had created the
perfect specimen so what was next
dr morristead had to know
everyone is sick
049 told dr morristed after the two had
talked for a couple of minutes the great
pandemic has started fear not doctor i
have a cure
no longer will you humans spread your
disease i'm afraid you are wrong replied
the doctor this pandemic you speak of
does not exist
we can happily live with our pathogens
we have done so for millennia dr
morstead became angry that he couldn't
get through to zero four nine i'm afraid
you are suffering from paranoia it is
you who need to be cured you have no
idea said 049 standing up what are you
doing shouted morristead you promised
you wouldn't hurt a human again i'm not
hurting you i'm healing you 049 said and
leapt across the room in a flash placing
a hand on the doctor's head moorstead
slumped to the ground they were being
watched in the observation room and this
had gone too far he had to be moved to
the containment cells permanently mobile
task force epsilon 11 was right on the
scene and burst through the door
now imagine nation 049 said to himself
those humans have no imagination at all
he began walking towards the task force
who opened fire on the anomaly but the
bullets bounced off its black code and
mask scp-049
calmly touched each of the members of
the task force one by one draining the
life from them the last one standing
stopped firing and attempted to run but
again zero four nine leapt across the
room black cape billowing out behind him
and gently touched the man causing him
to drop to the floor zero four nine
stepped over the bodies of the fallen
team and walked out of the containment
cell the full details of what happened
next are available only to the o5
council what are sometimes called the
overseers the redacted report that is
available reads standard secure humanoid
containment cell research sector 02 site
19 subject
scp-049 date of breach redacted euclid
class scp-049 breach cell and
subsequently gained access to adjoining
rooms and nearby buildings breach lasted
approximately three days and five hours
total casualties redacted with redacted
number of survivors requiring
incineration therapy course of action
department of science alchemy division
suggested injecting anti-transmogrify
disinfected into class-d former
prisoners who were transported to sight
and allowed them to come into contact
with scp-049
scp failed to reanimate injected
prisoners and cure them
scp-049 acknowledged this failure and
surrendered to mobile task force alpha
1.
scp-049 then requested to be contained
corpses littered the facility around 20
in total their massacre had unfolded in
a matter of seconds despite their
advanced armor and heavy weaponry their
killer wielding an ancient sword he'd
somehow pulled from thin air looked upon
them with disdain weak unworthy
opponents he breathed heavily his torso
was covered with bullet wounds and many
had punctured his lungs it was enough to
kill a normal man 10 times over but not
him he was the ultimate warrior the
perfect killing machine he would need to
seek out an enemy more fitting for his
legendary combat skills he fled from the
chamber into a connecting hallway where
a giant metal door slammed shut behind
him at the other end of a hall another
door did the same he laughed at the
thought of someone thinking he could be
trapped so easily and charged towards it
but then large valves began to open all
around him torrents of freezing seawater
began pouring in filling up the chamber
and submerging him before he could reach
the door the warrior fought for breath
and yelled it far longer than any mortal
man could especially considering the
state of his lungs but water always wins
he soon gave his last gasp and floated
lifeless in the hallway and soon after
his body turned to dust and disappeared
in the briny water but he would be back
he'd always be back his brother was a
different story tall and handsome with a
strange sumerian rune tattooed on his
forehead he was practically a pacifist
and spent most of his days reading
conversing with the staff and wandering
the facility of his own accord upon
hearing of the latest incident at the
facility he gave a sign he knew on some
level that all of this was his fault
it'd been centuries millennia even but
was it too late to make things right six
days later the two are standing face to
face this meeting had been a long time
coming but it was always destined to end
in blood and pain the man with the runic
tattoo was unarmed the only thing he
carried was his regrets the warrior eyes
full of burning fury drew his sword and
not long after a head hit the floor who
are these two strange men and what is
the significance of this fatal meeting
in our own universe these two may never
meet again but that doesn't mean there
isn't a universe out there where they
will and it is that universe where
today's tale springs from the story
between these two began a long long time
ago when they were both set on a course
of destruction but to learn how these
two finally met once again we only need
to go back a few days while they seem
more human than a lot of beings under
the scp foundation's watchful eyes
there's no doubt that these two are
anomalous they're known as
scp-073 and scp-076
but better known as cain and abel from
the name alone most people with a basic
knowledge of the bible could tell that
these two have a connection but the
particulars were largely a mystery to
the foundation they wanted to know how
much of the story was actually true scp
researchers approached scp-073
aka kane and asked if he'd be interested
in reuniting with his brother one last
time it took cain three days to answer
yes but on one condition that he was the
only person who could abort the mission
the foundation mulled over this
requirement for three days before the o5
council finally made a decision cross
testing approved these two brothers
separated by millennia would finally
meet again and the scp foundation would
get to watch what happened when they did
of course for safety reasons the cross
test would take place in 076's
containment facility a bedrock chamber
200 meters beneath the sea that would be
the closest thing to safe this fateful
meeting could ever be though safe was
really a relative term when it came to
scp-076
his escape attempts were as frequent and
unpredictable as they were deadly and
everyone who'd ever worked with him knew
exactly why to the untrained eye would
seem strange to create such a complex
facility for a 3 meter squared stone
cube known as scp-076-01
but the cube isn't what's being locked
up here the real danger comes from the
corpse stored inside known as scp-076-02
but better known as able he's a lean
olive-skinned man who appears to be in
his late 20s but his most distinct
physical feature is the fact he's
covered in an elaborate network of
arcane and occult tattoos largely of
scowling demonic faces similar to those
found on members of the yakuza whenever
abel's corpse reanimates as it does at
random intervals everyone in his
vicinity is in terrible danger he's
capable of pulling bladed weapons out of
miniature dimensional rifts that appear
around him though he does this so
quickly that it seems as though the
weapons are simply materializing in his
hands despite the increasingly complex
efforts to contain him able has been
able to breach containment and go on
brutal rampages multiple times killing
scores of foundation personnel in the
process abel possesses superhuman
strength speed and durability during
prior containment breaches he was able
to shrug off rounds from 50 caliber
machine guns he's torn through
reinforced steel doors he's even swatted
bullets from both handguns and assault
rifles out of the air with a length of
steel rebar only killing him can truly
end one of these rampages and the
foundation has had to go to terrifying
lengths in order to achieve this during
past containment breaches he's been
drowned asphyxiated crushed burned to
death with a thermite grenade directly
inserted into his chest cavity and even
disintegrated by the activation of the
facility's on-site nuclear warhead this
may seem like overkill but if abel were
ever to make his way into a major
population center the fatalities would
be
well of biblical proportions even death
can't keep him down for long his body
will rapidly decompose and reappear
intact within scp-076
there's no telling when he'll reawaken
and his periods of inactivity can range
from hours to years because of this he
must be constantly observed by guards
highly proficient in close combat and
always ready to go toe-to-toe with
perhaps the most dangerous melee
combatant in history he's such a
proficient killer that there was once a
project aimed at weaponizing abel but
this turned out to be a disastrous
failure for the foundation when they ran
out of missions to give him abel's
thirst for blood caused him to turn his
blade on his allies with no remorse
hacking them up with the same ruthless
abandon he gave his assigned enemies
interestingly abel does seem to have a
twisted sense of honor he has respect
for combatants capable of providing him
with a real challenge and has even
expressed concern for guards he
considers to be respectable adversaries
but don't be fooled there is no
reasoning with abel either you kill him
or he kills you and trust us he's much
better at it than you are while he's
often overshadowed by world ending
anomalies or more talkative mass killers
like
scp-682 abel is one of the most deadly
creatures known to the foundation abel's
counterpart 073 is an entirely different
story despite his namesake being the
first biblical murderer this cain is a
far more enigmatic figure a tall man in
his early 30s appearing to be of middle
eastern descent he has two very notable
physical characteristics the
untranslated sumerian symbol tattooed on
his forehead and the fact that several
of his body parts namely his arms legs
spinal cord and shoulder blades have
been replaced by mysterious prosthetics
of unknown origin unlike able kane is
polite
non-confrontational articulate and
communicative he's even allowed to
wander the facility he's housed in
freely though with certain regulations
namely that kane is never permitted to
come into contact with plant life or
uncovered ground this is because in
spite of the fact kane doesn't appear to
harbor any malicious intent direct
contact with him causes plants to wither
and die and the ground to become
infertile if cain was ever introduced
into a natural environment again he
could unwittingly cause an ecological
catastrophe with his mere presence in
that sense he could almost be as
dangerous to large populations as abel
however kane's danger to flora is only
one of his several anomalous qualities
another is extraordinary mental
capabilities and a near perfect memory
his memory and ability to recall is so
good that some foundation personnel have
suggested using kane's mind as a kind of
backup server for the foundation's
collective knowledge but perhaps his
most well-known anomalous trait is his
ability to act as a kind of a mortal
human voodoo doll that's right any
damage inflicted on kane causes no
permanent injury to him and is reflected
back on the perpetrator while kane has
remarked on still being able to feel the
pain of these assaults he's functionally
immortal this damage reflecting ability
has even made performing certain kinds
of tests impossible as doctors
attempting to draw blood from kane have
found that their sample was actually
their own blood and their skin exhibited
the telltale bruising and puncture marks
of blood testing but of most interest to
the foundation right now was the fact
that kane has shown prior knowledge of
abel however he was cagey when
questioned he refused to add any
additional information and commented
that it would be best if he and abel
were never brought into contact but what
does never really mean when you live
forever kane finally did agree to the
test and while nobody know what caused
kane's change of heart the foundation
knew better than to push him and
potentially get the entire mission
scrapped kane was taken from his
facility and transported to the access
point of abel's underwater prison the
experiment's design was simple kane
would occupy a temporary residence in
abel's containment facility until he
next reanimated at which point the
interaction between them would be
closely observed perhaps it would take
weeks months or even years before abel
once again awoke and left his cube but
when he did cain would be there
thankfully as kane whispered soothing
words into abel's tomb the resurrection
took only minutes if you were expecting
a heartwarming reunion think again
kane tried to apologize but abel
immediately struck him with a
decapitating blow which due to cain's
damage reflecting properties caused him
to sever his own head instead kane
remained at abel's side as he
regenerated and as soon as abel did he
immediately tried killing kane again it
went on like this again and again and
again
it was an arduous process and eventually
even abel began to tire of it
the duo fell into a tearful embrace abel
asked his brother why he killed him so
long ago and kane apologized saying it
was the actions of a younger and more
foolish man in that moment the two
finally reconciled and having fulfilled
their bargain with their creator both
finally crumbled into dust peace at last
as we said this didn't happen to the
cain and abel of our universe but when
universes are more numerous than grains
of sand in an endless desert such a
thing has indeed happened somewhere out
there perhaps in a kinder universe than
our own we can only hope that cain and
abel may someday get to meet and find
the same resolution but until then these
brothers will remain one of the most
dangerous and fascinating duos in the
foundation's catalog
joseph and frank were two lifelong
squatchers no that isn't an insult
that's a self-given title for bigfoot
enthusiasts who are willing to head out
into the woods and search for the
legendary sasquatch first hand while
most squatchers will go their whole
lives without ever encountering one
joseph and frank were about to get lucky
they just didn't know what kind of luck
during a journey through the forests of
the pacific northwest frank spotted
something moving in the distance a huge
ape-like creature with grayish fur and
human-like movements frank thought he
was finally laying eyes on the mighty
bigfoot after decades of searching what
he didn't know was that he just made a
deadly mistake he had looked directly at
scp-1000
and there would be terrible consequences
frank was excited he just achieved the
life goal of any squatcher he tapped
joseph on the shoulder and directed him
to look in the direction of the creature
joseph followed frank's direction and
stared into the distance when his eyes
finally came into focus on the ape-like
beast he froze his brain just
short-circuited one second he was about
to encounter the holy grail of his hobby
and the next he was literally brain dead
joseph collapsed
in the distance the ape-like creature
disappeared back into the woods not that
frank even noticed he was too busy
trying to wake joseph but it was no use
joseph was gone and frank had no idea
why
the headlines read bigfoot killed my
friend most people either ignored it or
laughed it off just a couple of cranks
goofing off in a forest and one of them
had dropped dead who cares well one
organization cared the scp foundation
mobile task force zeta 1000 the
foundation specialized scp-1000 detail
were alerted to the reports they sprang
into action tracking down and detaining
frank for questioning they process a
million loony bigfoot lovers every year
and usually find nothing but the death
of frank's friend made it all too clear
they hadn't encountered a bigfoot but a
real genuine example of scp-1000
scp-1000 rarely ranks among the scariest
or most dangerous scps but
underestimating the creature is a
terrible mistake
because just looking at it gives you a
two percent chance of dropping dead on
the spot frank despite losing his friend
was one of the lucky ones the foundation
debriefed him before administering
amnestics and making sure that he'd
never venture back into those mysterious
forests in the pacific northwest region
director jones the site director charged
with a management of scp-1000
populations was given the information on
this latest case of an scp-1000 related
fatality it was a story he heard many
times before for director jones they all
seemed to bleed into one another so what
exactly is scp-1000 and how did it leave
poor joseph dead in the woods
scp-1000 is a whole species of large
hominid ape-like creatures they're
largely nocturnal but sightings of the
creature during the day aren't unheard
of they're omnivorous mostly seeming to
consume plants and insects and their fur
is usually gray brown black red or
occasionally white
the creatures have large eyes capable of
impressive vision nestled underneath a
pronounced neanderthal-like brow another
defining feature is the ridge of bone on
the forehead much like that of a gorilla
that is present in both sexes according
to foundation studies the creatures
exhibit a level of intelligence on par
with that of the common chimpanzee but
nowhere near that of us humans what they
lack in intelligence though they make up
for in size the adults can be as large
as 10 feet tall and weigh up to 600
pounds despite their great size and
impressive strength the creatures are
neither aggressive nor territorial in
fact they seem to instinctively avoid
humans mostly residing deep in the force
of the american pacific northwest and in
the himalayan alps there have been
sightings of scp-1000 on every continent
though the foundation has taken pains to
exterminate all scp-1000 populations
situated near human population centers
to prevent a potential disaster
considering the 2 chance of
instantaneous death upon visual contact
that brings us to our second question
what is it that makes these seemingly
harmless creatures so dangerous sadly
for both these unfortunate creatures and
us humans the danger is beyond the
control of scp-1000
according to foundation research
scp-1000 likely evolved alongside us
homo sapiens until a tragedy occurred
between 10 and 15 000 years ago a
mysterious extinction event eliminated
the vast majority of their species
leaving only one to five percent alive
in the aftermath
what happened it's believed that around
this time scp-1000 contracted what the
foundation refers to as an anomalous
pseudo-disease meet scp-1000
f1 a disease that is passed along at the
genetic level and is so durable that it
persists in the species to this day the
tiny fraction of the population that are
immune to its effects managed to survive
but the majority who aren't immune die
shortly after birth this is why the
overall population remains relatively
low to this day it's a disease that only
appears to affect hominids including
humans chimpanzees bonobos and
non-immune instances of scp-1000 any
hominid that lays eyes on a carrier of
the disease has a two percent chance of
experiencing immediate brain death while
a two percent chance of instant death
may not seem all that threatening at
least when compared to some other
nightmare-inducing scps the truly scary
part is that the percentage is
cumulative in other words the longer one
observes a carrier of scp-1000 f1 the
higher that percentage rises the greater
your chance of experiencing an abrupt
death
according to foundation studies the
percentage rises by around one percent
every 20 minutes and the percentage also
varies between specimens with some
exhibiting a terrifyingly high death
chance of 90
upon viewing this death chance continues
to occur in dead specimens if they carry
the anomalous pseudovirus while alive
though thankfully the risk doesn't
appear to apply to small fur or tissue
samples the foundation's true concern
actually goes far beyond scp-1000
themselves because of the species close
relation to homo sapiens there's a worry
that scp-1000 f1 could transmit to
humans causing our own species to meet a
similar fate if humans did indeed become
carriers of scp-1000 f1 it's extremely
likely that humanity would undergo an
unprecedented extinction event with
billions across the globe dropping dead
as brain death sets in on mass while
full extermination of the entire species
has been deemed unlikely this
existential threat they pose to humanity
more than justifies the occasional
culling of scp-1000 populations
that was a lot to take in right first
the creature we thought was bigfoot was
actually a new species of scp out in the
wild
and second these creatures could end
human life as we know it if they made it
into a population center but what you're
about to hear next a dark secret only
available to people with level 3 scp
foundation clearance is the most
shocking scp-1000 fact of all are you
ready the true secret of scp-1000 is
that what you've just heard is a lie
there is no anomalous pseudo-disease and
scp-1000 poses no pathogenic threat to
humanity whatsoever who would spread
such a thing the scp foundation of
course strictly speaking the foundation
has disseminated two direct lies about
the nature of scp-1000 the first is that
of the disease which does not exist nor
has it ever existed the second lie is
about the creature's intelligence level
they're far smarter than the average
chimp in fact they're every bit as
intelligent as human beings these were
all lies formulated by director jones
and the foundation as was the very
existence of the bigfoot myth
the foundation has been spreading
information that makes the very concept
of the sasquatch out to be a joke for
decades all to discredit and further
push the very concept of scp-1000
into the shadows
but why the foundation is no stranger to
coming up with cover stories but why
would they put intentional lies into
their own files to anyone below a level
3 clearance well that all comes down to
the horrifying truth behind the origins
of today's scp-1000 population the
creatures were first brought to the
attention of the foundation by outcast
members of the serpent's hand an
organization dedicated to defying the
foundation's activities
these members known as the children of
the sun told them the secret history of
scp-1000 well at first foundation
personnel like director jones didn't
want to believe what they were hearing
they soon came to terms with the
horrifying truth
humans and scp-1000 did evolve alongside
each other with humans occupying the day
and scp-1000 the night however while
humans were still basic hunter-gatherers
scp-1000 were undergoing vast
intellectual and societal development
they were able to create tools
weapons agriculture stable settlements
domesticated animals and eventually even
fully developed cities it was like
nothing the world had ever seen and
wouldn't see for thousands of years to
come their numbers swelled into the tens
of billions as they created culture and
technology hitherto unimagined including
weapons of devastating power meanwhile
humanity was pushed to the brink of
destruction by their competitors rapid
and seemingly unstoppable growth it
looked as though the human species had
lost the evolutionary arms race and
would have to bow out but according to
the children of the sun a trickster
forest god smiled upon humanity and gave
them the power to use scp-1000 weapons
and technology against them 70 of
scp-1000's population were wiped out in
a single horrific day known to the
children of the sun as the day of the
flowers as every flower supposedly
bloomed that day during the massacre
humanity destroyed the entire
civilization and with the same
technology they stole from these
unfortunate creatures the vengeful
humans drove the apes mad their higher
consciousnesses were blocked out
reducing them back into the states of
mere animals once the massacre was done
and everything that was built had been
destroyed we the human race used the
scp-1000 weapons to wipe any memory of
the atrocity from our own minds the
advanced civilization of scp-1000 had
been wiped from history
humans returned to their plotting path
of evolution none the wiser for
thousands of years all the way up until
today this time remained a mystery to us
so again why did the foundation lie to
us what did they have to gain by
convincing us all that it was dangerous
to even look at these creatures well as
the frequency of sightings and the
attempts of communication increased
people like director jones became aware
of a frightening possibility what if the
pendulum was swinging back
what if the apes were regaining their
lost intelligence and worse still
harbored feelings of revenge for what we
did to their species thousands of years
ago
even the mere possibility that they
could do to us what we once did to them
is a chance that the foundation simply
cannot take and thus limiting contact
between humans and scp-1000 at all costs
is an absolute must however in spite of
the foundation's fears one intercepted
message from the apes suggests that
their paranoia may be misplaced this
message translated from an attempt at
communicating with foundation personnel
reads simply as follows we forgive you
given choice for now not forever
let us back in it's enough to make you
wonder what species the foundation
should really be keeping tabs on here
after all when it comes to netting out
violence and death humanity has a track
record to rival the worst creatures in
the foundation containment cells and few
examples illustrate that better than the
tragic case of scp-1000
ask yourself a simple question is the
world around you real it seems like the
answer should be pretty obvious of
course the world as you know it is real
how else would you be able to interact
with it perhaps a better question would
be this how much do you trust that the
world you know is real
how much do you believe that reality as
you experience it is constant and cannot
be changed by external forces
now imagine if you can an entity to
which the very fabric of reality is like
clay able to be shaped and molded at
will
then imagine that this entity this
malicious twisted and unknowable horror
has taken a special interest in you
if you can picture such a scenario then
you may as well be standing in the shoes
of james talaran a foundation researcher
assigned to scp-3999
talaran could only have imagined what
the foundation kept contained in an
airtight cell all the way at the bottom
of a kilometer long shaft and never
expected that this was where his
lifeless body would be found despite
having the entity contained the
foundation's only knowledge of scp-3999
came from a text document discovered on
taloran's phone after his demise
even their own records indicated that no
such creature ever existed why
what could possibly shape reality in
such a way that it could hide its own
existence from the foundation
and where was it now the document on
tolerance phone yielded some evidence
seeming to be a long rambling and
confused account of some sort of battle
between a reality-shaping entity and the
ill-fated researcher sent to examine it
unlike many of the foundation's
documents the entry for
scp-3999 is riddled with contradictions
and strikethroughs
a confusing mess of information that
makes piecing together the mysteries of
tolerance fate all the more difficult
beneath the strange formatting and
uncertainty surrounding scp-3999
lies the tale of one man's torture for
the amusement of an impossibly powerful
and eternally sadistic creature
based on the information available it
appears that
scp-3999 was fixated on talaran upon his
arrival to the entity's cell the
researcher had no idea how long he would
spend in the company of scp-3999
or that he would never emerge alive many
scps contained by the foundation require
their own specially made prisons in
order to hold them and maintain the
safety of foundation staff as well as
the outside world but imagine if an scp
could turn the tables
bending the world around a single member
of the foundation using all of reality
as their own personalized torture
chamber the list of horrors endured by
talaran is both exhaustive and
incomplete given the length of time he
spent with the creature shortly after
james talaran was assigned to site 118
where
scp-3999 was contained the entity was
somehow able to breach containment and
began to twist the world around it in
the name of a singular cruel objective
the torture of james talaran
the creature while having no physical
description possessed the capability to
cause either a ck-class reality
restructuring event or a zk class end of
reality event
scp-3999 was somehow able to both
destroy reality itself while
simultaneously rebuilding it around its
prisoner researcher talaran
every creature person and machination
that scp-3999
created was done so with the express
intention of making tolerance suffer
horribly
over the course of millions of years
according to the researchers own
writings
the exact details of how
scp-3999 tortured talaran are littered
throughout the document he was found
with but it is apparent that the entity
was able to use its reality altering
abilities to continually revive the man
after killing him as a way to prolong
his pain
scp-3999
seemed to be able to use its powers
however it pleased but focused all its
attention and actions on causing misery
for one man it simply enjoyed inflicting
suffering
one of the examples of the atrocities
james tolerance suffered at the mercy of
a cold remorseless creature was
witnessing the deaths of others
although they were constructed and
controlled by scp-3999
taloran saw train foundation security
personnel drag three people into the
cell
he recognized them instantly as his own
family
taloran was made to watch as his mother
father and sister were executed with a
single gunshot to the head by members of
the same organization that he was a part
of all of tolerance professional
colleagues were also killed in front of
him followed by anyone and everyone that
had come into contact with james talaran
including the o5 council
he was made to watch as they were
systematically murdered one by one all
for the enjoyment of scp-3999
at some point during the creatures
torture of talaran there appears to have
been some attempt to contain scp-3999
within another scp scp-2432
a room within a hotel now owned by the
foundation that appears to compel its
guests to write exaggerated positive
reviews after staying there
when introduced to scp-2432
scp-3999's ability to alter reality
seemed to have the effect of creating a
dimensional anomaly within the hotel
a crawl space opened up in scp-2432
leading to an almost identical room
the front door of this new room
designated scp-2432-1
led to an alternate dimension that
resembled the hotel housing
scp-2432 the rooms of this new version
of the
scp-2432 hotel were a seemingly infinite
endless loop of rooms
this dimension also played host to a
number of strange creatures as uncovered
by foundation research teams that
ventured there most notably a creature
resembling a male homo sapien calling
itself researcher talaran this being was
dressed in clothing similar to
foundation researchers and appeared
nervous and confused when approached by
personnel only to be executed when asked
to be told the location of scp-3999
later during
scp-3999's three million year torture
session james talaran was interviewed
with another doctor working for the
foundation
the interviewing doctor had no
recollection of tolerance assignment to
scp-3999
and both james's involvement with the
foundation and the very existence of
scp-3999 were expunged from the
foundation's database
as talaran desperately tried to
rationalize what was happening to him he
told the interviewer
i have trouble focusing on things now i
just feel a lot of unease it's like
reality has started to feel less
real
if that makes sense shortly after he
attempted to ask the doctor for his name
and for him to identify which of the
foundation sites they were at in
response the doctor admitted a strange
noise from his mouth confusing talaran
that's not a name you just made a noise
with your mouth the researcher replied
why am i thinking of redactions how can
a word be redacted like that in a normal
conversation
following this the floor beneath james
talloran's feet disappeared and he was
swallowed by darkness as scp-3999
continued bending reality to make him
suffer
what followed were multiple failed
attempts from talaran to either escape
from the entity or nullify its abilities
to warp reality
scp-3999 had at a later point trapped
talaran in a stage play version of
itself as james frantically tried to
escape out of a nearby door where he
hoped to find reality he was met with a
solid wall i'm trapped in whatever this
place is with this thing and there's no
outside reality anymore he realized
researcher talaran tried to understand
the entity
but
scp-3999 defied description it was
simply chaos
in his desperation talaran was able to
dig a tiny hole in the floor through
which he could see a light filled with
thoughts of his beloved family his
colleagues and the rest of the world
that had once existed he opened the hole
wider it is unclear what happened after
this but it is apparent that james
talaran was still unable to escape as cp
3999 however as the situations he found
himself in grew increasingly strange
james talaran was able to take greater
control of his predicament this is
evidence in the foundation's document
regarding scp-3999
researcher talaran cannot be contained
by this researcher taloran will fight
his way back
researcher talaran will re-contain
scp-3999
this torture had gone on long enough and
researcher james talaran was determined
to be free of the creature that had
taken such sick pleasure in his pain
tal'erin at one point was able to subdue
scp-3999
although it is initially unclear how he
accomplished this
there were several attempts made to
contain the entity using a recursive
joke a melon the graves of american
crime novelist robert b parker or an o5
council member and a roach motel
it is believed that every single one of
these attempts failed attempting to beat
the creature at its own game talarant
tried to turn
scp-3999's reality altering powers
against it by imagining the entity as
something easier to subdue
these included several moldy blankets a
murderous penguin and a pillow
eventually telerin was able to contain
scp-3999 with the aid of 48 train
containment personnel all of whom were
also researcher talaran during this time
a conversation between the two were
partially recorded although any dialogue
from
scp-3999 suffered from data corruption
claiming to finally be in charge and in
control of the situation talaran
interrogated scp-3999
berating the creature for keeping him
prisoner you can't frighten me anymore
for the first million years of
nonsensical containment procedures and
tortures and dream logic it was the
worst pain i had ever felt but i
survived for the second million years it
was still the hardest thing i had ever
done
but i survived by the third million
years
i was growing numb
the researcher tried to ascertain the
exact nature and origin of scp-3999
but to no avail
vowing to fight the entity taloran told
it here's the thing about horror and
weirdness the more you reveal of it the
less effect it has i am sick of your
horror
i am sick of you
afterwards he was melted into goo for
five years it appears that shortly after
this
researcher taloran managed to understand
how to destroy
scp-3999 while the entity was immortal
and virtually unstoppable he realized
its weakness that it had to bond to
another being in order to survive
upon discovering this talaran took his
own life causing all that
scp-3999 had done to disappear after
foundation researcher james talaran
committed suicide reality reverted to
its original state
before
scp-3999 had heavily altered it
his death freeing reality from the evil
entity once and for all the foundation
remains unaware of what
scp-3999 was or indeed is and one can
only guess as to why the entity
subjugated talarant to such terror and
horror what made this powerful reality
bender hold such a perverse fixation on
one man
some have liken the creature to a horror
rider continually subjugating a
character to all manner of nightmares
before deciding to re-draft and try
something new
whatever it was
scp-3999 carries with it a warning that
reality isn't always as it seems
we were a team
despite our differences
in spite of the terrible things they've
done
we were still a team
that's not how the higher up saw it
though
no
the guys upstairs with their perfectly
pressed shirts
for them we were judged by our level of
expendability and they knew that our
next mission was a death sentence
one by one that thing
took out my team
my friends
snapping their necks so quickly and with
such ease that no sooner did i hear the
scream
they were dead
we had been used
i'd been used
delivered as prey to the predator
a plot that was sanctioned by the bosses
and approved with a blood-red stamp
why did they do it
i'm still trying to figure that out
maybe that's something you can tell me
after you hear how these so-called
scientific men left us in the cell
and in the hands of scp-173
for me it had been the best of times
before it became the worst of times the
best because i'd quickly risen through
the ranks of the facility
the worst because well
i'll get to that
i was never the best student i finished
high school by the skin of my teeth and
my job prospects looked bleak
but i was lucky i guess
or at least i thought so at the time
you see i have an uncle siegfried who
did some work for the government
i never actually knew what he did just
that it was secretive work
i used to imagine he was some sort of
super spy so you can imagine how excited
i was when he found out i needed a job
and he offered to help me out
i couldn't believe it
i always thought he hated me
i'd overheard him telling my parents
that i was a no-good deadbeat but now
he'd have a change of heart and was
willing to take me under his wing
but what i get to do
undercover intelligence gathering
international assassinations
just you wait he said
that's how i found myself walking into a
sprawling futuristic looking facility
where they handed me a level one
security clearance card with big bold
letters that read
janitor but i was happy
just the words security clearance made
me feel important and it beat flipping
burgers
i pushed mops turned off lights fired up
generators clocked in and clocked out
but all that time they must have been
watching me
grooming me
waiting for the day they could throw me
to the wolves
i should have known
i've always been an expendable kind of
guy
after a few years i was called to an
office and there was a man in a plaid
shirt and kind of a tweed jacket that
professors
he asked me
do you have any idea about what we
actually do here
and to be honest
i didn't i knew that there were many
parts of the facility i couldn't enter
i imagine that down a maze of corridors
were weapons being built or prisoners
being interrogated but i had no idea
about the anomalies
how could i before i was told anything i
had to sign a bunch of forms there were
so many i thought i'd get to find out
who really killed jfk
and while they didn't come out and say
it what i inferred was that if i ever
talk about what happens at the facility
to someone outside the facility well
let's just say it's not the kind of
thing they'd spell out on a piece of
paper but it involves padded cells and
rusty tools
i wasn't scared though
i was part of something big
something secret
and i loved it so i signed my life away
with no hesitation
soon after i was introduced to my first
anomaly the safe class of course
they took me to an observation room from
that room i could see into another room
with a sign on the wall that read
scp-067 i just stood there waiting for
something to happen when in walked
another guy in a white lab coat welcome
to your first anomaly lisa is it okay if
i hook you up to this heart monitor we
want to gauge your reaction to what you
see
all i can see i told them is an empty
room with a table and what looks like a
pen on top of some papers
correct he said half smiling as if i was
some kind of idiot
that's
scp-067
i thought about telling him that if i
needed years of training before i could
see a pen that i probably should have
taken that fast food job could have been
a shift manager by now
then they brought a young chimpanzee
into the room small enough to be
harmless one of the guys forced a pen
into the scared shim's hand and
something strange happened
it started scribbling
nonsense at first but suddenly it was
sketching and drawing faster and faster
i could catch glimpses of words and
images by the time they dragged it out
it was flailing around like it was
possessed that pen has power said the
man in the lab coat a power whose source
or origin we don't fully understand
that's why we're here
that's why you are here one of the guys
in the other room held the chimps
drawing up to the window it was a
perfect sketch of the tower of london
intricate and brilliant
above the sketch was the title tower of
london tudor period circa 1541 the year
margaret poll the countess of salisbury
lost her head on the chopping block
underneath that the chimp had written
pity she was no traitor
take it from me
i was there they didn't need to look at
the heart rate monitor to see that i was
shocked
that was far from the only anomaly i'd
come into contact with and i must have
been doing something right because in
time i went from level one to two to
level three security clearance and
that's when they made me a containment
specialist i won't bore you with all the
details but as you can guess i dealt
with the containment of anomalies a lot
of my time was spent looking through
small windows and cell doors
making sure that whatever was inside was
still inside and still in one piece
other times i worked with field agents
when anomalies were brought in a
transition period that the arrested
freaks didn't much like
there was one certain anomaly though
that i was tasked to oversee on many
occasions i like to think of it as my
pet but in hindsight
i was its pet
this was
scp-173 something that was in what we
call the euclid class classification
meaning that we don't fully understand
it but know it is very dangerous
we know it's intelligent we know it's
unpredictable
and we know it will kill and for that
reason there's people tasked with
containing it and keeping an eye on it
at all times
at first glance you wouldn't guess just
how dangerous 173 is you wouldn't think
it's incredibly intelligent in fact
you'd think the opposite
that's because it's more or less a
walking slab of concrete and rebar with
stunted limbs and traces of spray paint
that give the impression of a dopey face
we have to enter its cell twice a week
for cleaning duties it leaves a
disgusting foul-smelling liquid on the
floor a reddish-brown substance that i
can only describe as a mix of blood and
waste
that stuff comes from has remained a
mystery since we first contained it in
1993.
going into the cell was always a
three-man job because and this is maybe
the weirdest part about 173
it can't move if human eyes are watching
it that's why you need at least two
people watching it at all times if you
were in the room watching 173 by
yourself and blinked you'd be dead
before your eyes opened
we don't know how it moves that fast but
in that fraction of a second your neck
is snapped so hard it's almost like
being decapitated i've seen the videos
to prove it
all it took was a sneeze he wasn't even
finished getting the rest of the achoo
out when there was a flash and his
partner was left lying on the ground
his head twisted around the wrong
direction
so you can understand why we now require
three men for any time we must enter 173
cell
then a few months ago i was told that a
long process would begin to train and
re-educate some future class d's
class d's are mostly prisoners with
lifelong sentences or those we've taken
from death row and given a new lease on
life we were apparently understaffed so
why not employ these men whose lives had
pretty much ended anyway that was the
rationale or at least that's what they
told me i was told to train them on
their new job mopping up 173's mess so
that me and the rest of the containment
specialist could focus on more important
tasks
they hadn't been through the training i
had seen what i had seen
but after showing them the video of 173
nearly taking off a man's head they were
more than willing to follow the rules
they understood not to blink or turn
away or sneeze
and that any lapse in focus could lead
to a violent death so i started to show
them the ropes how we move as a team
into the cell and always keep the others
informed on what we're doing
173 was always sitting in the corner of
a cell no expression on that crude face
but when we walked in itself i got the
feeling it knew something had changed
i felt almost as if it was communicating
with me but i couldn't tell what it was
trying to say
and then
it happened
it was a tuesday afternoon three days
from the last time we'd cleaned as usual
173 had covered the floor with that
horrible liquid we headed in to clean my
new team alert as always and some of
them cleaned while others kept their
eyes focused on the thing in the corner
things were going smoothly when we heard
a noise i knew very well
it was the sound of the cell door
locking
someone must have screwed up
hey guys we're locked in here i shot it
through the intercom
nothing
guys the damn door is locked
nothing
i lost it a bit open the door will you
nothing
my team looked at me
the ones not on eye contact duty that is
as if i should know what to do
hoping that this had happened before and
that there was some kind of standard
plan to deal with it
there wasn't
we were always observed when in the room
and i knew that a technician couldn't
accidentally lock the door it was
impossible there were protocols
someone had done this on purpose
the four of us sat in the corner of the
room as far from 173 as possible our
eyes locked on it it didn't move an inch
as usual just stood staring at the wall
as it always did
we stayed awake through the night
talking a little holding on to the slim
hope that something had gone wrong
but as night turned to day again we all
began to lose hope we weren't sent here
to clean
we were a test
totally expendable
lab rats but i wouldn't go down without
a fight we couldn't just stay up forever
that was a death sentence i suggested
that two of us stand one sit and rest
and one get some sleep
we take shifts a couple hours on a
couple hours off
maybe we could show that we wouldn't
give up they'd have time to realize what
they were doing was insane call off the
test and come free us
we made it through a couple of shifts
like this and it seemed like we'd
actually be able to make it another day
or two when everything went wrong
it was my turn to sit and rest when i
heard the worst possible noise
snoring
the con next to me was sleeping quietly
so it must be one of the standers i
glanced over for just a split second and
saw both of them
leaning against the cell wall dozing at
the same time i saw the flash crack snap
pop
one after another their necks were
snapped
i'm not sure how it happened but i was
standing again staring at 173 who was
now in the corner dead bodies with their
heads twisted around piled up in front
of it
i couldn't take it anymore i couldn't
stare at this thing forever i felt
myself giving up
i lowered my head to the ground and then
finally broke my gaze ready to die
and then
nothing happened i slowly raised my head
back up and there it was it's hideous
face inches away from mine it was then
that i understood what we'd been
containing what we'd underestimated
i felt it again like it was telling me
something
it was telling me to close my eyes
to sleep
so i did but as my eyes closed i didn't
see darkness
i saw 173
or something like it
but not in the cell
i saw it outside
in the world
standing over children sleeping in their
beds
watching
i saw them hiding in the shadows
staring out at passers-by
then i realized they weren't watching
waiting to pounce
no
they were hiding
my eyes popped open as the door opened
and in rush six security personnel
they took me outside jabbed my leg with
a syringe injecting me with something as
the world
faded
away
incident report time and date redacted
following the experimental forced
interaction with euclid class anomaly
scp-173
subject has ceased responding to
external stimuli and appears to have
taken on the traits and behaviors of the
anomaly subject now spends entire days
sitting in corner of cell staring at the
wall
staff are advised to proceed with
caution when dealing with subject as the
only behavior they engage in is an
attempt to strangle anyone who enters
the cell
no treatments have shown any
effectiveness and subject will
unfortunately require incarceration
likely forever
mobile task force edna 84 also known by
the code name and thus upon his crucible
is on one of the strangest missions
they've ever been sent on they sit in a
darkened room beads of sweat trickling
down their brows the lights of computer
monitors shine upon their faces they're
tackling a monster that if it escapes
will literally devour all of creation it
has no fear it has no remorse and if it
isn't kept contained by edna 84 it may
escape and wreak havoc across the world
oh and did we mention it's trapped in a
minecraft server you heard us right
scp-4330
is a cognitohazardous extra-dimensional
being of pure terror trapped inside a
procedurally generated world in the
immensely popular game minecraft you
hear about a lot of horrifying monsters
being described as lovecraftian but only
this monster is minecraftian there's a
lot that needs explaining here and we
intend to get to all of it but let's
start with how the foundation keeps this
truly exceptional piece contained the
foundation first discovered
scp-4335 back in 2010 shortly after the
alpha version of minecraft was released
because of the online nature of the game
it's proven to be impossible to contain
4335 externally seeing as it isn't
confined to any one physical location
shutting off the server 4335 is found in
is not an effective containment method
either as this just causes the entity to
simply hop to a different server the
foundation's greatest fear is that 4335
will one day make the leap out of
minecraft and cause chaos in our world
that's why it's imperative to draft
containment procedures for
scp-4335 within the game this led to the
creation of a containment site unlike
any other site m1 the first official
foundation site made entirely out of
minecraft blocks everyone who was
originally involved in the server has
been removed and anesthetized since then
elite scp foundation containment
specialists and gamers have been
constructing the perfect prison for
scp-4335
site m1 is a large stone complex built
into the side of a mountain it has a
number of key features including a
supply area filled with materials vital
for 4335's continued containment chests
filled with books that contain
scp-4335's containment procedures a few
animal farms for the purpose of breeding
and killing livestock for their meat the
entrance to a mine several chests
containing books specifically designed
for civilians to learn about 4335
if they ever breach containment and
enter the server and of course the
actual containment chamber for scp-4335
itself which is a little more
complicated 4335's containment chamber
is built out of several layers all made
from iron blocks the outermost cube is
75 by 75 by 75 blocks the inner cube is
55 by 55 by 55 blocks and the innermost
cube is 25 by 25 by 25 blocks creating
several levels of defense finally one
layer within all these others which
contains the anomaly proper is made from
obsidian blocks
scp-4335 is bound into the center of the
containment chamber with a complex
mechanism the outermost cube is
completely filled with water and several
dispensers capable of rapidly dispensing
large amounts of items in a short amount
of time line the cube the cube also
contains several mob farms which are
devices that constantly spawn enemies
into the chamber that drop loot when
they die the chamber is essentially
designed to funnel a constant flow of
items inwards to scp-4335
there are even contingency measures for
if
scp-4335 manages to breach containment
if escape is attempted blocks of tnt
detonate above the ceiling causing lava
to pour into the chamber at that point
mtf edna 84 dispatched into the server
to lure 4335 back into its containment
chamber to do this they fire a mix of
fire resistant potions and ender pearls
which have teleportation capabilities
interestingly there's one more basic
method of luring
scp-4335 back into the obsidian cube
taunting and insulting one of
scp-4335's many anomalous abilities is
being able to hear people through the
screen and being a proud creature it
often responds to insults by charging in
to directly engage the insulter if
scp-4335 still manages to breach the
containment that has been set up for it
then they even expect that it will
likely soon hop into another server at
that point the goal will shift to
finding the monster and recontaining it
with containment procedures this complex
and extensive it shouldn't come as a
surprise that
scp-4335 rests firmly in the ketter
class what exactly is this anomalous
entity why does its containment hinge on
constantly providing it with items and
how did it end up in mojang's popular
building and survival game in the first
place
scp-4335 in terms of physical dimensions
appears almost identical to the player
character with an all-black skin it also
appears to be constantly shrouded in a
cloud of smoke particles and as long
black tendrils protruding from its back
in some respects 4335 has been compared
to two popular creepypasta figures
herobrine and the slenderman but 4335 is
far stranger its physical body behaves
similarly to most assets native to the
game with a few peculiar anomalous
abilities we'll discuss soon handling
scp-4335 is an extremely delicate
process if command blocks creative mode
or server commands are ever enabled in a
server with scp-4335
the server will instantly shut down and
scp-4335 will move to a different server
scp-4335 also uses its tendrils to
destroy surrounding blocks before
consuming them with each successful
consumption
scp-4335 grows and when it reaches
sufficient size it hops to a different
server as you can see keeping
scp-4335 contained is an uphill battle
but luckily there are two factors on the
foundation's side here the first is that
scp-4335 is immobilized while consuming
items and blocks limiting its ability to
actively escape foundation forces the
second factor is that
scp-4335 needs a rest period between
consuming blocks in order to grow
meaning if its consumption is constant
and continuous it isn't able to grow
these two factors have informed the
entirety of the foundation's containment
procedures around
scp-4335 it's locked into its chamber
and fed items and blocks constantly
effectively rooting it in place when
scp-4335 begins to grow the foundation
also found that the application of ender
pearls helps reduce it back to its
normal size however
scp-4335 does have a method of striking
back against its captors 4335 is a
virgin-class multi-sensory cognito
hazard anyone viewing it without proper
training and protection may experience
distressing hallucinations
scp-4335 is also capable of telepathic
speech with people playing on its server
and as we alluded to earlier it can also
hear any noises you make while playing
weird is a term thrown around a lot when
it comes to scps considering it's pretty
much a requirement for the foundation to
take interest in you but an
all-devouring minecraft demon that can
hear you talking through your screen is
strange even by foundation standards mtf
edna 84 first discovered
scp-4335 and the single-player server of
minecraft user leaking heart three team
members jason yelsen richard duchamp and
shelia freemason covertly entered the
game to investigate and potentially
apprehend the creature when leaking
heart first discovered their presence on
what he thought was a private server he
quickly left a little creeped out by the
sudden intrusion thankfully the trio was
still able to locate scp-43 scp-4335
they discovered the creature hiding
inside a giant crater as though it had
impacted the earth at considerable speed
richard duchamp who was the leader of
the team at the time made the mistake of
looking directly at the entity in that
moment he experienced the full force of
scp-4335's cognito hazardous effects he
hallucinated believing that his keyboard
was melting before his eyes in the
aftermath of this incident duchamp was
taken off the case and jason yelsen was
promoted to head of the project things
were still going to get stranger yelsen
was able to open a dialogue with the
creature after containing it in a
chamber filled with lava it asked him
whether it had landed in the right
location meaning our world and yelsen
informed him that it's somehow fallen
into the world of minecraft instead the
creature was at first confused and then
angry and resentful about its situation
it vowed to find its way into our world
somehow and obtain more sustenance a few
months after this the entity managed to
breach containment and hop into another
server yelsen and two others once again
managed to track it down and recontain
it but this time two civilians also
inhabiting the server were exposed to
the anomalous effects of scp-4335
they weren't heard but they did appear
strange and incoherent after
experiencing 4335's cognito hazards the
foundation tracked them down in the
aftermath and gave them amnestic
treatment
4335 was contained shortly thereafter
once again yelsin came face to face with
his new foe eight months after being
captured 4335 granted yeltsin another
interview from containment 4335 admitted
that it almost respected yeltsin and the
rest of the foundation for figuring out
how to capture and contain it so quickly
in exchange it would give the foundation
something extremely valuable information
first it asked one question of yelsin
how does he define creation
replied uh something that is built and
brought into this universe by a sapient
being using other things from this
universe
4335 agreed it went on to explain that
it came from a universe devoid of
creation a dark and unknowable place
filled with nothing but violent random
chaos its dimension existed directly
above ours and it often looked down at
us through a dimensional window
fascinated by all the creation below it
plotted and dreamed to one day
infiltrate our reality and yelsin
finally had the opportunity to ask the
magic question why
though he wasn't quite ready for the
brutal honesty of
scp-4335's reply i do not like to lie so
i will tell you now
i wish to suck it dry if the toys of
whatever force controls your universe
destroy the light destroy the earth and
destroy humanity it reminded me
of me
a blubbering mass of intelligence and
order it sickens me in ways i cannot
comprehend
i hope you understand
scp-4335 was a connoisseur of creation
and it sought to devour all of it in
this moment yelsin realized what an
incredibly dangerous entity he was
dealing with the only mystery was why
this creature had somehow landed in
minecraft instead of our world which
appeared to be the only thing that saved
us but yelsin didn't have time to think
4335 was about to stage another daring
escape attempt one of its tendrils
reached out and attacked yeltsin's
player character in that moment the
real-life yelsen began to hallucinate
and panic suddenly back in the game a
series of abnormally tall slender black
figures appeared and began
deconstructing the containment chamber
around
scp-4335 it had somehow summoned new
minions into the game to assist in this
containment breach jason yelsen entered
cognitohazard quarantine following this
incident and was removed from the
project and he wasn't the only one
affected by this incident following the
first appearance of these long dark
figures players across the globe began
to experience them appearing in their
own games the foundation managed to find
a solution they contacted mojang and had
the creatures patched into the game
during the next update as a new
non-anomalous entity which seemed to
stop 4335 from being able to use them as
its own tools they're now known as the
endermen and are beloved among fans for
being one of the creepier enemies to
this day containment efforts continue
for scp-4335
but there's only one question left why
did the entity fall into minecraft
rather than our world the file posits
the most likely answer because 4335
defines creation as elements made by
sapient beings in minecraft the most
popular game in the world at the height
of 4335's power everything that exists
is the product of code made by humans
creation is truly abundant there as for
our world in
scp-4335's extra-dimensional eyes there
is no creation no intelligent design no
soothing piano soundtrack just
frightening chaotic randomness which is
too unlike its own dimension so even if
scp-4335
ever did arrive in our reality we would
likely be disappointed by how little
there is to eat
it's the late 90s and an air canada
flight experiences severe malfunctions
while traveling from london to vancouver
the pilots are unable to do anything and
the plane crashes into the woods of
northern alberta the crash was
devastating only 10 of the nearly 300
people on board are alive and even
though they survived the initial
disaster their battle for life has only
just begun it's late autumn in northern
canada and there's no telling when help
will arrive if at all if the survivors
want to make it through the night they
need to find shelter and fast as they
trudge through the freezing woods the
group finds a path that looks like it
might lead them to civilization
after all if there was a path in the
woods that meant they were probably in a
national park and if they were in a
national park there had to be a ranger
station around somewhere where they
could warm up and call for help they
didn't have many other options so they
followed the path which opened up to a
clearing but instead of finding a ranger
station or campground they found
something none of them could have
expected it was a pond but there was
something off about it as they got
closer they saw that this strange pond
wasn't filled with water but blood the
survivors were horrified that couldn't
really be blood could it it must have
been a weird algae or chemical reaction
but one member of the group a man named
thomas dean who had been on his way back
to his hometown of prince george british
columbia thought there was something
strangely familiar about this he
remembered being a boy and going to
visit family in alberta and hearing an
urban legend from the older local kids
according to the stories somewhere out
in the wilderness in the northern part
of the province there was a pond full of
human blood and what made it even worse
was that some said the pond was a
gateway to hell the scp foundation was
also aware of this legend and had been
trying to pinpoint the exact source of
it for decades prior to the air canada
crash they would finally receive
definite confirmation of the blood pond
when foundation personnel intercepted a
radio transmission from a ranger station
located within the wood buffalo national
park it was the survivors of the crash
who had managed to make it through the
night and they were about to be escorted
out of the park by rangers the
foundation mobilized quickly to cordon
off the pond as at the time they were
unsure of what potentially harmful
properties the pond might have had they
set up watch station epsilon 38 and put
staff on guard to deter travelers from
the area the pond was given the
designation of scp-354
and classed as euclid foundation
scientists made a number of interesting
discoveries about scp-354 when they
collected samples for testing first the
pond was not in fact full of blood
merely an inorganic liquid that closely
resembles blood in color and consistency
second and even stranger than the red
liquid is that the pond doesn't seem to
have any definite banks or a bottom
instead the liquid in the pond increases
in density as the radius away from the
center increases the liquid congeals at
the edges becoming more solid and
blending into the surrounding soil it
also becomes thicker as one descends
deeper into the pool and the bottom of
the pond has not yet been reached if it
even exists initially the foundation
found no signs of life within the blood
pond but that would all change at 203 pm
on the day following the opening of
watch station epsilon 38 when the
science team noticed an unusual level of
activity on the pond's surface security
footage feeds showed a shape rising out
of the pond followed by a deafening
shriek after that the feed was cut and
foundation lost all communication with
watch station epsilon 38 fearing the
worst a mobile task force was dispatched
to the location when they got there all
personnel at the watch station had been
killed by what could only be described
as a gigantic bat the task force was
able to neutralize the entity and as
soon as they could the foundation moved
in to increase security around the scp
creating area 354 and installing a
permanent security detail after this
point the pawn started to regularly spit
out a variety of monstrous entities
almost as if it was reacting to the scp
foundation's increased security measures
after
scp-354-1 the giant bat came
scp-354-2
354-2 was an echidna-like monster the
size of a bear that was virtually
bulletproof but unable to escape area
3-5-4 the foundation neutralized this
anomaly with napalm
scp-354-3 was a floating black sphere
capable of firing deadly beams of
concentrated energy the area's head
scientist was able to hit it with a
sledgehammer causing the sphere to
malfunction and self-destruct before it
was able to escape the area the
foundation wasn't as lucky with
scp-354-4
this creature was a reptilian humanoid
that stood roughly 15 feet tall and was
unable to be put down with gunfire this
was the first creature from the pond to
successfully escape containment and was
only able to be neutralized when the
foundation sent in mobile task force
omega 7 also known as pandora's box the
data on pond incursions is partially
corrupted so a complete list of
creatures is not available but some of
the other monsters that came out of the
blood pond include a killer robot a set
of gigantic tentacles that drag several
d-class personnel into the pond a pair
of panther-like creatures one made of
ice and the other of magma that ignored
foundation staff and instead fought each
other and one seemingly normal human man
who was executed as soon as he emerged
from the pond tests on his body revealed
that he was in fact totally normal and
would have posed no threat these
anomalies came out of the pond at fairly
regular intervals for several months
before the pond went silent for an
unprecedented 22 months the head
scientists at the time noted i suspect
this means one of two things either the
red pool has died or powered down or
whatever the correct term for it is or
is charging up for something big to come
through o5 believes the former is the
most likely explanation and has recalled
30 of our total personnel and cut 25
percent of our funding well i can only
hope that they are correct if the latter
situation is true we're soon to face
some terrible monstrosity and we won't
have anywhere near the force necessary
to deal with it i worry for all of our
safety his words would prove eerily
prophetic following the events of
exploratory mission 354 alpha the
foundation's research and development
team built a specialized craft to
explore the pond because of the strange
properties of the pond's density the
craft was essentially made to be both a
submarine for parts of the pond where
the contents were liquid and a drill for
when the liquid congealed into a
semi-solid towards the bottom the
exploration team consisted of agent
swanson agent turquoise agent 86
dr j mcarthur chris simmons leroy tucker
and a pilot named martin with the team
assembled the ship was sent down into
the pond nothing eventful happened for
the first two days of the mission but at
4 30 am on the third day gravity
suddenly reversed for the crew of the
ship this seemed to indicate that they
were approaching the halfway point
though what would be on the other side
nobody could say on the fourth day the
ship surfaced proving definitely that
the pond was in fact some sort of portal
the crew looked out of the portholes to
see the darkness of night above them
while sensors outside the ship detected
nothing harmful in the atmosphere around
them the crew were wary of exiting the
craft the other side of the pond was
nothing like the world the crew knew for
one thing the night lasted for 28 hours
before dawn came and when the sun
finally rose it was much larger and
redder than the earth's sun under the
light of the strange red star the crew
could see that the pond on this side was
massive compared to what they've come
into more like a large lake surrounding
the lake was sand and rocks that were
covered in a kind of moss that
disappeared under sunlight and re-grew
during the night the team left the ship
and started to explore during their time
in this strange world they found that
the day lasted just a few hours shorter
than the night meaning that whatever
planet they were on had a roughly
43-hour long rotation as opposed to our
own planets 24. the team found a number
of anomalous elements on their
expedition including razor-sharp grass
that can puncture skin and streams of
liquid carbon dioxide they heard some
loud roars in the distance once or twice
but other than that the planet was
eerily silent with seemingly no animal
life and not even wind when it rained
the soil remained dry and based on that
the scientists theorized the plants in
this world were more efficient at
absorbing moisture on the 25th day the
team ran into a huge metal wall that
appeared to be artificially constructed
luckily leroy tucker a quick thinking
researcher was able to rig a blowtorch
from camping supplies and melt a hole
through the metal on the other side
there was finally wind and odd black
grass that's the extent of what is known
about the other side of the wall because
the expedition logs are heavily
corrupted after that point but we know
that whatever was in there wasn't good
because the team never returned
strangely there's no record of any names
mentioned in the ship's log almost as if
being killed on the other side
completely erased them from history no
other expeditions into the pond were
launched after that on an undisclosed
date a year following the discovery of
the blood pond and construction of area
354 the site was completely evacuated
and power was cut to the area mobile
task force data 12 was dispatched to
investigate the cause of the evacuation
but before contact could be established
the area's on-site nuclear warhead was
detonated completely destroying the site
mtf theta 12 was then attacked by a
convoy made up of d-class and other
low-ranking staff who had evacuated area
3-5-4 it was apparent that there had
been some kind of mutiny within the site
and that a dissolution of the chain of
command had led to its evacuation and
destruction the convoy totally
annihilated mtf theta 12 and no further
contact with the former personnel of
area 354 has been made since following
the site's detonation a new site was
constructed called simply the red pool
containment site unlike the previous
facility which focused on research and
neutralization the new site is entirely
concerned with containment the shift in
directive came as a response to the
pond's apparent reactive nature each
creature that emerged from the pond
seemed to be in retaliation to the
foundation's actions and it was
theorized by some that the mutiny at
area 354 was triggered by some kind of
psychic attack from the pond itself an
interview in the scp file on 354 reveals
that there was one more disastrous
attempt to control and understand the
blood pond according to an interview
with a foundation agent the head doctor
proposed a scheme to drain the blood
pond using a system of pumps and hoses
all non-essential personnel were
evacuated in case of emergency leaving
only the pump technicians d-class
personnel and a few agents for security
however as soon as the pump was
scheduled to be turned on everyone at
the side experienced a mass dissociative
episode the agent described the feeling
they all experienced as like being in a
dream and suddenly realizing that you're
asleep he said everything stopped being
real it was like we had to escape right
now when asked what happened when the
pump was turned on he simply explained
that it wouldn't let them this interview
confirmed the theory that the pond is
not only capable of releasing monsters
out into our world but also that it's
capable of powerful but much more subtle
psychological attacks this suggests a
chilling possibility that the pod isn't
just blindly reacting to being attacked
but it's fully sentient and the actions
of the scp foundation have only served
to annoy it and worst studies of the
pawns banks have proved evidence that
the area of congealed liquid around the
perimeter of the pond has been steadily
expanding that's right the pond is
getting bigger the last thing the
foundation agent stationed at the site
said before being dragged out of the
interview and sedated was it gets bigger
and stronger every day and now we've
made it angry
one of the primary aims of the scp
foundation is to contain the anomalies
that they discover secure contain
protect is their mission statement after
all however there are some forces so
unknowable and malevolent that there is
no way to truly contain them
scp-4205
is one such force
very little is known about scp-4205
even compared to other scps many of
which are mysterious by their very
nature
we do not know what it is we do not know
what it wants and we do not have any
meaningful way to stop it the best that
can be done to protect yourself from it
is to implement the few known
preventative measures available and pray
that it doesn't set its sights on you
the little information that exists on
scp-4205 was recorded by wade dallets a
former junior researcher at the
foundation he wrote the initial report
on
scp-4205 on a computer terminal 4 though
his work was highly valuable and
provided many previously unknown
insights about the nature of the scp
sadly his knowledge could not save him
the official entry on
scp-4205 was his final act before his
death on december 11th 1992.
before we get deeper into that entry and
wade's final day on earth it's important
to understand what scp-4205
is
or at least understand the little we
know about what it is 4205 is a ketter
class scp meaning that it's incredibly
difficult or complicated to contain it
also shows extreme hostility toward all
life it is described as an amber colored
pair of human-like eyes with the ability
to appear spontaneously in windows
mirrors or any other glass or glass-like
surface one of the reasons so little is
known about these eyes is that anyone
who sees them dies within seconds
much like the mythical basilisk the gaze
of
scp-4205 is deadly and inescapable the
eyes only seem to appear to people who
are alone in a room and never in places
where there's more than one person
but aside from that there is no way to
predict where the eyes will appear since
it is unknown if the eyes are part of a
corporeal body or even present on this
plane of reality there is no way to
contain them or stop them from killing
this brings us to that fateful day
december 11th 1992 the day that the scp
foundation would finally be given some
tangible information on the mysterious
amber eyes
at the cost of one of their researchers
lives
wade dallas a young man fresh out of his
university studies was brought on board
as a junior researcher by dr mark
forsythe a senior researcher dr forsythe
recruited wade after giving a guest
lecture at his university and being
impressed by wade's keen observational
skills thirst for knowledge of the
unexplained and determination to
understand that which seemed to defy
explanation
after wade graduated he was recruited by
dr forsythe and given the position of
junior researcher at the scp foundation
where he assisted dr forsythe now a site
supervisor in his research
after several months of working under dr
forsythe with minimal responsibilities
wade was finally given the opportunity
to write his first scp report on
scp-4205
following some initial documented
appearances of 4205 dr forsythe approved
further research into the anomaly with
wade appointed as the lead researcher on
the subject
according to wade's entry he was
responsible for the discovery of
scp-4205 when he spotted the anomaly in
a window the later reviews of security
footage determined that he was not the
first person to observe the eyes
he did claim to be the first to observe
them and live to tell the tale
in his writing on the subject wade is
puzzled by the fact that he survived his
encounter with scp-4205
and wonders what could have set him
apart from the others that fell victim
to its gaze
he found himself frustrated as he
documented scp-4205
his rough drafts of reports dissolving
into angry rants about his own
incompetence wayne had difficulty
adjusting to his new responsibilities
especially with the added element of his
assigned subject's mysterious and
volatile nature in between his reports
on scp-4205
its previous appearances and its effects
on its victims he wrote letters to his
father desperate for reassurance that he
was not messing everything up letters
that would sadly go unsent
in his coverage of scp-4205
wade made note of a troubling recurring
element in each victim's death when
medical professionals attempted to
revive the victims it was always noted
that their brain activity stopped much
more quickly than in cases of death by
natural causes when examined all aspects
of the body aside from the brain were
completely unharmed the brain however
showed massive nerve damage in the
amygdala hippocampus medial temporal
lobe and occipital lobe the appearance
of this brain trauma had been compared
to the effects of electrical shock or
severe head injury in addition to wade
six other people on record encountered
scp-4205
every encounter ended the same way with
sudden brain death and severe nerve
damage immediately after viewing the
eyes in a reflective surface the first
encounter occurred on january 5th 1990
when deputy lia zangena viewed the eyes
in a reflective glass one-way window
security tape reveals that the eyes
appeared in the window eight minutes
before the deputy liaison spotted them
as soon as he did he fell from his chair
and immediately died though the
specifics varied from case to case the
end result of every encounter was the
same with none surviving long enough to
relate what they had experienced every
encounter except wades as he continued
his documentation of scp-4205
wade's mental state quickly began to
deteriorate the process of his mind
coming apart and his thoughts giving way
to confusion fear and anger at his own
survival is documented in his reports on
the scp he agonized over the questions
of why he was able to survive gazing
into the eyes of
scp-4205 when so many others had not the
question consumed him until he was
unable to eat sleep or do anything but
obsess over the scp he was tasked with
researching
as he became more agitated he began to
write about the eyes appearing to him
again on one occurrence he attempted to
touch them and described the sensation
like touching a balloon to your arm
after it had been charged with static
electricity he continued to report
seeing the eyes the worse was when
trying to sleep during which he was
overtaken by violent sleep paralysis and
plagued with visions of the amber eyes
the only comfort wade seemed to find was
in memories of his loved ones he wrote
about his mother and his father even as
their memories grew foggier to him he
also mentioned a man by the name of
theodore quayle who he claimed was a
researcher at the foundation later
fact-checking determined that this was
not the case and that quail must have
been someone from wade's past he wrote
about quail wistfully mournfully with
words of love and loss tormented by the
sense that he was losing his grip on
reality and everything he once held dear
as wade descended deeper into a hell
inside his own mind he continued to mull
over the questions of scp-4205
was there more to it than what was
visible did it have a body why had he
survived the encounter with it and what
did it want from him he decided that
those who had perished immediately were
the lucky ones they had escaped the
torture that had overtaken his life the
eyes were everywhere now watching him
even as he attempted to unlock their
secrets on a foundation computer he
spoke to the eyes at one point but
refused to write down what they said to
him
his last entry his last thought was a
plea for theodore quail's embrace
there is no more written about the
research or about the eyes only a simple
desperate need for a comfort that is
long lost
now is the part of our story where
terror meets tragedy contrary to what
wade thought and what was recorded in
his final computer entries
he did not survive his brief brush with
scp-4205
the truth is that he spotted the amber
eyes and the glass above his terminal
monitor while recording the entry and
died seconds later though his death was
swift it felt agonizingly slow as
revealed by his descent into panic and
paranoia recorded in his writings the
entries recorded as a result of the
connection weighed in the computer his
physical contact with it at the moment
of exposure to
scp-4205's anomalous effects allowing
the terminal to archive his final
thoughts before he succumbed to the
deadly nature of the eyes
the entries were never physically typed
but rather jump from his dying mind into
the mainframe his entries the echoes of
a dying mind offer a glimpse into the
way that scp-4205
kills its victims in the seconds leading
up to death the amber eyes fast forward
a person's mind feeding on the
electrical impulses that it gives off as
it speeds through what seems to be days
of fear and of a loosening grip on
reality the death may be swift but the
suffering is long
wade left the foundation with a digital
fingerprint an echo of the person he was
at his core in addition to his
experiences with
scp-4205 itself wade spent his final
moments terrified for his life dreaming
of a father that he missed and a long
lost love from his college days
his sacrifice must not be forgotten
because no one ever survives an
encounter with scp-4205
his documented final moments are the
only first-hand account in existence
junior researcher wade dolits gave us a
gift in death
he allowed the scp foundation a glimpse
into the true horror of the amber eyes
and a reminder of what they are capable
of stealing from us
so be careful of windows mirrors screens
and all reflective surfaces
when you look into them
you never know what you might see
looking back
the young girl stood silently in a room
full of corpses
staring off into the distance
she was in a trance
seemingly unaware of the carnage that
had just unfolded around her
some of the men were shot or stabbed or
beaten
others had no apparent cause of death
whatsoever
but the young girl was unscathed she was
wearing a yellow summer dress and looked
like she couldn't have been more than
three years old she awoke from her
trance still paying no heed to the
violence in the room
and left
this is the story of scp-053
the young girl
her strange and terrifying life before
containment her thrilling capture
and the part she played in one of the
most dangerous scp foundation cross
tests of all time
she had no name
the young girl could never spend enough
time around someone to be given one
it was her terrible courage that she
could never stay in one place for too
long or something truly awful would
happen to everyone around her she'd been
drifting for years
but never grew to look older than a
child her memories were long but
formless divided mostly into 10-minute
increments the young girl kept on moving
it was all she could do
in 1993 when the young girl had already
been alive for a very long time
she found herself in illinois after days
of trekking on the roadside she would
scavenge what little food she needed
from the trash and drink from lakes
rivers or even puddles when she needed
to
deep down the young girl knew that if
she ever grew hungry or thirsty
she would not die
in her travels the young girl had
managed to scrounge together a few
dollars and though she knew her contact
with people had to be limited
there was one thing she wanted that felt
worth the risk
a candy bar
it'd been a long time since she tasted
chocolate and she found the idea of
tasting it again too enticing to resist
when she reached chicago she entered a
small corner store with her handful of
dollars selected the candy bar from the
rack and approached the counter for
reasons even she didn't fully understand
she kept her eyes down as she placed the
money on the counter
you see
scp-053 was always a special child as we
briefly mentioned earlier you might even
say she was cursed whenever she was
around other people for too long
terrible things tended to happen
unspeakable things and as a component of
this strange unexplainable curse or
perhaps as a means of keeping her safe
from it the young girl was doomed to
never understand the nature of her
predicament
it was like there was a mental wall
between her and the horrors her presence
could cause
all she knew was that it was best to
avoid eye contact stay away from large
groups of people at all costs
and never spend any longer than 10
minutes around anyone
ever that's why as she waited for her
chocolate bar at the cash register she
kept her head down and waited to go
the cashier looked upon this strange
girl with apparent concern it'd been a
slow day all in all a few listless
patrons milled around the store window
shopping his brain was practically on
autopilot until he saw this child
she looked filthy in a disheveled dress
and was totally alone
what on earth had happened to this child
the more he looked at her the more he
sensed a creepy vibe exuding from her
something about this girl was wrong
he spoke softly to her introducing
himself as miles
and asking her where her mommy and daddy
were
the young girl hesitated for just a few
seconds too long for his liking before
simply saying that they were at home any
parent who'd let their three-year-old
kid just wander around the south side of
chicago alone was either crazy
neglectful or both
he asked her politely to remain in the
store while he gave the police a quick
call
he'd even let her have the candy bar for
free while she waited
immediately the little girl became
uncomfortable she had already been in
here for a few minutes now and while
miles called the police he expected her
to wait around even longer
again she couldn't even tell you why she
knew waiting around like this would be
so dangerous but she had a nagging
instinctual awareness that she needed to
get out around the store the few patrons
still inside started to get a strange
feeling
like someone was watching them
soon what seemed like mild paranoia was
quickly becoming white hot anger
pure rage they felt almost like they had
to kill someone but not just anyone
someone particular
they had to kill the little girl it
wasn't long until the police arrived two
officers holliday and dewitt entered to
collect the apparently neglected little
girl
it was a story they'd sadly heard all
too often a tragically common occurrence
in the big city
when the two of them approached the
young girl she was looking down at the
ground they tried to speak to her but
she was unresponsive miles looked on
concerned but deep down he felt the same
bizarre progression all the other store
goers were feeling
confusion irritability and finally
violent rage
the corner store was a powder gig
all it needed now was a spark
and that spark came when officer
holliday reached down and took the young
girl by the arm
his bare skin touched hers and it was
all over
the cop twitched his mind washed out in
murderous insanity as he reached for his
sidearm
officer dewitt opened his mouth to
protest but he didn't manage to get a
syllable out before holliday turned and
shot him in a fraction of a second the
quiet corner store exploded into a
violent bloodbath as the patrons and
cops slaughtered each other all the
while the young girl just stood there in
a trance
everyone was dead within minutes except
miles and the young girl he shakely rose
to his feet his mind carved out by
madness and reached for officer
holliday's discarded pistol
outside of the store the young girl
appeared walking out as if nothing had
happened
inside miles's body was sprawled over
the counter clutching his chest as if
his heart had just exploded this was the
true nature of the young girl's curse
anyone who meets her eye touches her
skin or spends over 10 minutes around
her is destined to slip into a state of
murderous insanity
they'll go into a kill-crazy frenzy and
attack anyone around them
until all that is left is them and the
young girl
at which point they'll try to kill her
too but the mere act of attempting to
kill her is also fatal
killing its victims with a massive heart
attack or a seizure
the second part of the girl's curse is
that she herself can never die
she keeps coming back
unknowingly causing more misery and
death along the way
until of course a certain secret
organization took notice that night the
young girl sat in the cavernous interior
of a local abandoned warehouse quietly
eating her hard-earned candy bar
suddenly she heard a quiet crack in the
distance she tried to move her left arm
but found it was numb she could barely
move it the girl turned her head and saw
a tranquilizer dart sticking out of her
skin instinctively she got up and began
to run limping as her left leg started
to lose all feeling too suddenly she was
surrounded by footsteps as masked men in
swat uniforms emerged out of the
darkness on all sides
the last thing she remembered before
slipping out of consciousness was a
blindfold being pulled over her eyes and
tiny metal handcuffs clasping over her
wrists
when she woke up she was in the nicest
room she had slept in in years
it was 16 feet by 16 feet with toys
books and games
standing across the room from her was a
stranger in a full hazmat suit connected
to a long steel cable leading out of the
room he spoke calmly and politely a
timer on his wrist counted down from 10
minutes
the stranger explained to the young girl
that they would be taking care of her
now and would provide her with all the
toys and games and treats she wanted
provided she cooperated and submitted
willingly to some tests
compared to living out on the streets
with no food or comfort this seemed like
an excellent compromise
she would live in what seemed like
luxury and every so often she'd be taken
to a testing room with a stranger in an
orange jumpsuit
after a few minutes of waiting the
stranger would inevitably go feral and
attempt to kill her and then always die
in the process the strangers in the
hazmat suits told her that all of these
tests were helping them learn extremely
valuable things about her and that soon
they'd have a very special job for her
it would be a wonderful surprise it was
the spring of 1994 that the young girl
now officially designated scp-053
finally received her special mission
several strangers in full hazmat suits
wielding rifles escorted her out of her
usual bedroom
she asked where she was being taken and
was told she was going to meet a new
friend she was taken to one of the
recreational testing rooms and pushed
inside out in front of her she saw
something terrifying
a giant reptilian creature she retreated
from it instinctually hiding behind a
chair in the containment area the giant
reptile didn't move they just sat there
eventually she plucked up the courage to
go and touch the creature before
retreating again
no reaction little by little the young
girl gained confidence and continued to
approach and pat the creature it exhaled
through its huge nostrils and the young
girl literally jumped for joy in her
amusement she began to play with the
docile monster hugging it even drawing
on it with a crayon the observers were
truly baffled what the young girl didn't
know was that she was playing with
scp-682
one of the most hateful and aggressive
anomalies under the foundation's
watchful eye
and yet in her presence the creature was
like an overgrown puppy dog after the
test phase the young girl was removed
from the hard to kill reptile's presence
immediately causing the creature to
become violent and murderous once again
after being separated from her strange
new friend the young girl was seen
crying for several minutes
according to all accounts the young girl
is eager to see her friend again someday
though considering the reptile killed
several guards after their separation
the foundation isn't eager to grant her
that wish
scp-053 was classified as euclid and
continues to be held in containment with
her toys books and games rotated out on
a regular basis
seeing as she shows no sign of aging
this ongoing containment is likely to be
the sad strange fate of the young girl
an anomaly that never wanted to hurt
anyone but an important and cruel
reminder that what we want doesn't
always influence the world in the way we
want
cast your mind back to the height of the
cold war the ever accelerating nuclear
arms race brought us closer than ever
before to making the nightmare of
nuclear armageddon a terrifying reality
the two main parties in this conflict
are the united states and soviet union
each amassing huge amounts of nuclear
warheads and jumping on any available
advantage they can over their enemies
what you may not know is that in order
to detect an impending attack from the
united states the soviets developed what
would become known to the west as the
dead hand but this experimental piece of
technology also had another name
scp-1984
it is no secret that the soviet union
feared the threat of u.s nuclear strikes
an invasion just as much as the u.s
feared an attack from them so scp-1984
was created to act as a deterrent
mechanism specifically against secure
second strikes secure second strikes
were both a deterrent and overwhelming
concern during the cold war referring to
a country's ability after suffering an
initial nuclear attack to still
retaliate firing on their enemy and
causing untold damage with their own
arsenal of nuclear weapons the soviet
union knew that any action they made
that could be perceived as an attack on
united states soil would be threatened
with nuclear retaliation and that if
they fired first america would return
fire and potentially annihilate them
with a second strike
scp-1984 was to be an automated system
that would activate in response to the
destruction of the soviet's main command
and control structure given that the
dead hand was created during the 80s you
might be forgiven for expecting a
nuclear detection system built at this
point in history to consist of various
sensors connected to a computer network
but you have also probably already
realized that if this was the case then
the foundation wouldn't be so interested
in it in actuality
scp-1984 is a fully autonomous entity
rather than a network of sensors for
detecting incoming nuclear strikes or a
computer capable of initiating a second
strike perhaps what makes the foundation
more interested in the dead hand is that
it is both self-aware and links
simultaneously to every single one of
russia's nuclear launch sites not only
this but
scp-1984 also has direct access to every
single one of the atomic weapons
stockpiled by the soviet union during
the cold war and is capable of launching
intercontinental ballistic missiles at a
moment's notice in short
scp-1984 could very easily and
horrifyingly quickly trigger an all-out
nuclear war resulting in the extinction
of all life on earth no wonder the
foundation considers the dead hands such
a massive threat
scp-1984 itself actually consists of the
preserved remains of a russian soldier
by the name of sergeant marat chernikov
who was killed during the soviet afghan
war in 1982 most of the official
documentation of chernikov's existence
has been expunged by the russian
federation it is only referred to in
fragmented documents recovered by the
foundation that referred to a project
december these remains serve as the
location of a semi-sentient
consciousness that has been classified
as scp-1984-01
when it remains dormant and is not
interfered with
scp-1984-01 has the ability to receive
and process any signal broadcast to it
and is able to decipher information
combined in any signal it picks up
however when global military tensions
start to climb especially when those
tensions affect the russian federation
or what were once the satellite states
of the former soviet union the entity
begins to manifest itself in the
physical world and usually in various
strange and different ways
scp-1984-0
has been known to appear in the real
world in forms such as a humanoid
outline or a bright red spectre taking
the shape of a child with its legs cut
off regardless of which shape it appears
in it is when the dead hand manifests in
a more physical form that the wider
scope of its abilities become clear as
mentioned previously it can influence
and even launch nuclear weapons
overriding their command systems and
bypassing launch sequences after
appearing fully
scp-1984-01 will travel at speeds of up
to 140 kilometers an hour directly to
the nearest military installation
capable of launching intercontinental
ballistic missiles once it reaches its
destination
scp-1984-01 will immediately attempt to
override the necessary systems to
initiate a launch after firing missiles
at their predetermined targets
scp-1984-01 will hastily travel to
another facility housing nuclear
ornaments repeating the process until it
has successfully launched all of
russia's atomic weapons when engaged the
physical manifestation of scp-1984
is highly aggressive and will lethally
defend itself against anyone that it
observes trying to interfere with it or
stop it from causing a nuclear launch
the entity has displayed the ability to
disrupt the nervous system causing
excruciating pain and debilitating
damage to human beings its only known
weakness if any is a susceptibility to
microwave radiation although exposure to
this does not seem to cause any lasting
damage to scp-1984
instead only temporarily disorienting
its physical form as for the origins of
scp-1984
the soviet union's official liaison with
the scp foundation offered some clarity
on this ironically during early 1984 the
liaison a doctor named sergey described
information regarding the dead hand as
being of grave importance to the
continued survival of the human race
seeing as he was referring to an enemy
that could single-handedly launch the
soviet union's entire nuclear arsenal he
certainly had a point a top secret
conference was held in sarajevo between
the foundation's o5 council and
officials from both the ussr and the
united states using the 1984 winter
olympics as cover avoiding too many
questions about several nations
high-ranking state officials being in
the same place at once the o5 council
was then given full in-depth information
about the dead hand something they had
previously assumed was a more
conventional form of nuclear deterrence
scp-1984 was far more and worse far out
of the control of the russian government
it was revealed that the entity had been
designated outside the original
specifications given to those who
developed it initially the soviets had
intended for the dead hand to be solely
used as a secure second strike response
if the leaders of the soviet union were
killed
scp-1984 would react in kind to russia's
enemies launching back all of the ussr's
nuclear missiles in retaliation this is
more likely where the dead hand nickname
comes from hearkening to the idea of a
dead man's switch picture that you had
been mortally wounded by your worst
enemy shot in the stomach and laying on
the ground rapidly bleeding out you know
that there is no chance you will survive
but you cannot afford to let your enemy
get away what they don't know is that
you rigged the entire building around
you both with explosives with your dying
breath you activate the detonator
assuring your own and your enemies
mutual destruction kaboom then curtains
for both of you the pressing issue and
the reason this secret summit between
the ussr usa and scp foundation was held
was that
scp-1984 was no longer interested in
just waiting for russia to be attacked
and only reacting after the fact instead
the entity's physical form was trying to
preemptively strike at the enemies of
the motherland attempting to activate
nuclear launches and send atomic weapons
to destroy the united states france west
germany and the people's republic of
china in other words the dead hand was
eager to get a head start at causing
total nuclear annihilation not to
mention potentially killing millions and
reducing target countries to little more
than irradiated craters awash with
deadly nuclear fallout both the soviet
union and the united states begged the
scp foundation to intervene and contain
scp-1984 and under the direction of the
o5 council they stepped in to take
direct control of the situation
establishing new containment procedures
in the hopes of keeping
scp-1984 from hitting as many launch
buttons as it could find the embalmed
remains that seemed to create the
manifestations of the dead hand entity
were held securely in an armed
containment complex near verkhoyank part
of the saka republic within the russian
federation
scp-1984 was placed within a standard
humanoid containment cell which was
itself held within a faraday cage a type
of enclosure constructed with or covered
in conductive material designed to block
electromagnetic fields this was done to
block any external broadcast signals
from reaching
scp-1984 and thus causing it to manifest
its other form if it learned of an
impending attack on russia even a
fictional one perhaps as a part of a
television broadcast as part of the dead
hands containment all signals broadcast
near its cage are to be monitored and
only broadcasts featuring doctored
information would reach the entity
thankfully to the work of the scp
foundation's information control team
scp-1984 is drip fed a stream of
carefully fabricated information using
on-site equipment and facilities a team
of military historians economists actors
and soviet media specialists the
information control team have created an
ongoing narrative wherein the cold war
never ended through falsified radio and
television broadcast made to look like
era-appropriated news organizations they
managed to keep
scp-1984 convinced that the nuclear
stalemate between the soviet union and
united states is still ongoing
unfortunately sometimes information from
the real world is able to bleed through
an incident involving
scp-1984 occurred on august 8th 1984 and
almost brought forth a full-scale
nuclear war while preparing for a
campaign speech the 40th president of
the united states ronald reagan uttered
the following joke i'm pleased to tell
you today that i've signed legislation
that will outlaw russia forever we begin
bombing in five minutes naturally
thousands of media outlets reported on
this but signals of those broadcasts
including recordings of the president's
remark made their way to scp 1984.
foundation researchers were both unsure
of how these transmissions breached the
faraday cage surrounding the dead hand
and were unable to prevent what happened
next hearing what it could only assume
was a genuine declaration of war the
manifestation of the
scp-1984-01 entity happened immediately
after reagan's words reached its
containment cell this time the entity
appeared as a semi-transparent woman
withered in blue wearing traditional
pashtun dress armed personnel guarding
scp-1984's cage engaged the entity
causing it to retaliate lashing out and
attacking any that stood in its way one
captain and two privates that suffered
the brunt of
scp-1984's offensive capabilities began
bleeding heavily from their ears seizing
violently most gruesomely of all a
liquid leaked from their eyes and nose
believed to have been cerebrospinal
fluid while armed personnel attempted to
use microwave emitting weaponry to slow
the entity down the information control
team was frantically trying to record a
new falsified broadcast in the hopes
that
scp-1984 would cease its hostilities and
the entity would dissipate before it was
able to travel at high speed to any
nearby soviet nuclear facilities and
begin bombarding the united states their
first attempt to record a new broadcast
that would result in a cessation of
scp-1984 slaughter of its guards was
interrupted when a nearby wall collapsed
desperate to recontain the creature the
information control team tried to film
the broadcast a second time and
succeeded although one of the actors
portraying a news reader suffered a
stroke and had to be edited out to
convince the dead hand of its supposed
authenticity what followed was a short
news clip clarifying that russia's
public bureau was in on president
reagan's joke including old footage of
the ussr's general secretary konstantin
chernenko confirming that the soviet
union's nuclear forces were not on high
alert miraculously after 15 more minutes
of sustained fighting with guards
scp-1984's physical manifestation began
to disappear gradually dematerializing
while it seemed to attack with far less
intensity eventually containment was
re-established at the cost of the deaths
of 17 members of foundation staff both
guards and researchers a further aid
however suffered traumatic brain
injuries that left them all permanently
disabled the one upside is that this
incident remains the only time
scp-1984 has ever breached its
containment and caused harm to others
and considering that it could very well
have launched russia's nuclear arsenal
the casualties could easily have been
much higher so remember folks don't joke
about nuclear weapons especially if
you're the president you never know what
anomalies lurking in the bodies of dead
russian soldiers might be listening and
if they are you'd better hope they have
a sense of humor
it's 3am and the facility is quiet
office workers and administrators roam
the halls security officers stand at
their posts clad in advanced tactical
armor and carrying standard issue m4
carbines three foundation employees sit
at flickering monitors watching a live
feed of footage from the containment
cell of the infamous scp-106
or as it's referred to by all staff the
old man no foundation personnel are
permitted to travel within 60 feet of
the cell for security reasons and nobody
is permitted to physically interact with
the anomaly without the approval of two
thirds of o5 command the observer's eyes
itch and sting from hours of unending
blue light exposure but they can't look
away the old man is crafty he might have
the insatiable bloodlust of a hungry
great white shark but he's not mindless
he's a calculating predator more
sadistic than the worst human serial
killer and he's always searching for the
next opportunity according to the
foundation records he's been active
since at least world war ii and it's
estimated that he has hundreds if not
thousands of victims to his name and
many of those made simple but extremely
foolish mistakes of underestimating him
after all it only takes a few seconds of
inattentiveness and the briefest moment
of distraction to give him the window he
needs to do what you ask oh don't worry
you'll find out just like they did the
old man has his nickname for a reason
most of the time he really does look
exactly like that an old man or more
specifically an old man's decaying
corpse his body covered in rotten dark
grayish black flesh that looks like
putrid meat though the creature has been
observed being able to change shape the
rod seems to run too deep for the old
man to ever hide it foundation employees
that have observed scp-106 for extended
periods of time have reported seeing it
assume the form of grinning decayed
children and women whose rotted flesh
barely hangs on their creaking bones
just seeing the images through a video
feed is enough to cause a lifetime of
insomnia and other sleeping issues still
they have a job to do and the cameras
remain fixed on the old man he's been
completely motionless for three months
just sitting there like a buddhist monk
in deep meditation a novice might see
this period of inactivity as a cause for
celebration but those with experience
know that this is merely the calm before
the storm scp-106 can remain in a
dormant state for months at a time
described by the foundation scientists
as a lulling state it's believed that
the old man simply waiting for its
captors to get soft make a mistake or
simply have a momentary lapse in
concentration which is all it needs to
make its move it had happened so many
times before and it was about to happen
again one of the observers must have
felt an overwhelming wave of anxiety as
he saw the creature ever so slightly
twitch just a tiny quiver in the
shoulder muscles but that was enough to
tell the observer that their day had
just taken a terrifying turn he grabbed
the emergency phone fixed to his desk
and practically screamed into the
receiver that 106 is moving that they
need a tactical team stat but he was
already too late he and the other two
observers stared into the monitors with
their mouths of gabe as a gooey
rust-like substance began to pool around
the creature on the floor of itself
slowly the creature craned its withered
neck around its face was fixed into a
broad yellow-toothed lip-less grin its
eyes had the kind of dull flat malice of
an underwater predator it looked
directly into the camera directly at
them and smiled the observers knew this
was bad really really bad with what they
could have sworn was a little nod the
old man began sinking into the rusty
puddle it made on the ground beneath it
until it had disappeared entirely
scp-106 is capable of phasing through
any solid surface with ease making it
one of the hardest entities to reliably
contain and earning it a spot on the
dreaded keter class reserved for the
anomalies that are complete nightmares
to keep locked up through the years of
costly research and deadly trial and
error the foundation would later devise
ways of at least slowing the creature
down it's shown to have an aversion to
lead highly complex or random physical
structures and intense bright light none
of these cause harm to the creature as
far as we know literally nothing can but
they'll at least buy you some precious
extra seconds with which to at least try
and escape seconds the three observers
didn't have one of them grabbed an
emergency line again and barked into it
that they lost visual on the anomaly
just then the observers heard a faint
crackling sound behind them and the
hissing of a chemical burn they turned
in horror to see a huge rusty burn mark
expanding across the wall right next to
the door which was their only escape
route they backed as far away from the
doors they could as a rotten hand began
reaching out of the massive corrosive
black sludge followed by the grinning
face of scp-106 ready to have some fun
meanwhile two heavily armed security
officers agents goodwin and resnick came
charging down the corridor toward the
observation rooms it became a bleak
slogan during scp-106 escape attempts
that all you need to do is follow the
screams and that motto was proven true
that night because awful things were
happening to the observation personnel
they were certainly screaming about it
of course even with the top of the line
firearms there was little they could do
to harm the rampaging old man he seemed
immune to all forms of physical damage
all they could hope to do was keep the
thing distracted until the scientists
and containment specialists finished the
preparations to lure him back into his
containment cell goodwin surged forward
while resnick covered his six vigilance
was key as unlike a standard human
combatant scp-106 could attack from
literally any angle including above or
below physical obstacles were irrelevant
to him and no cover was safe the
hardened security officers could see the
burn mark on the wall of the observation
room as they approached scp-106 was
perpetually coated in a thick black
mucus with powerful corrosive properties
that left any surfaces it touched
permanently marked foundation scientists
speculated that this mucus served as a
kind of pre-digestive substance that
tenderizes meat and bone alike but to
what purpose this serves is a mystery as
the old man has never been observed
eating it's postulated that the only
purpose is causing additional pain
goodwin and resnick knew to treat this
hissing sludge as a potential threat as
the corrosive properties would remain
active for as much as six hours before
finally fizzling out the two officers
shared a quiet nod before goodwin
breached the observation room door with
a hard kick the two of them searched
inside guns at the ready in their time
working at the foundation they'd seen
some truly horrific sights from the
mutilation of d-class personnel
typically death row prison inmates
brought in for use as scp guinea pigs to
the violence and mayhem of a containment
breach but there was nothing in their
past that would ever make the horrifying
sight they saw in the observation room
that night feel normal all three
observers were dead almost nothing
remained of two of them and the third
while still intact no longer looked
human he looked like he'd somehow been
dead a hundred years in the brief period
that the old man had been free his skin
was gray and completely dried out and
its mouth was locked into a perpetual
scream it was a massacre but there was
no sign of the old man goodwin grabbed
his radio and whispered this is goodwin
in observation room 6 requesting
immediate backup we have no idea where
this thing but his sentence was cut off
by a sudden scream from agent resnick
scp foundation security officers are as
tough as nails the best of the best you
might say recruited from the top
military organizations in the world so
hearing one of them scream in fright is
a rare if not impossible occurrence but
even they were forced to yell out in
fear when they looked up to see the old
man standing on the ceiling grinning
down at them resnick raised his m4 and
shot a three round burst at center mass
scp-106 didn't care even under sustained
gunfire from the two security officers
it didn't flinch the old man simply
reached down and snatched agent resnick
from the ground like it was picking an
apple from a tree the old man held
resnick in one hand and pounded its
other rotten fist into the agent's body
breaking all of his bones resnick
screamed for his partner to help him but
there was no time before goodwin could
do anything scp-106 began receding back
into another slimy burn mark on the wall
only this time he was taking his
screaming victim with him agent resnick
gave one more horrified scream before he
was pulled backward into the inky
darkness leaving the room silent except
for the burning hiss of the corrosive
goo left behind you might think this
would be the end of it but no for poor
agent resnick the worst was yet to come
he was being dragged into what the scp
foundation scientists refer to as the
old man's pocket dimension a miniature
layer of reality within our own where
the malicious scp is essentially a cool
all-powerful god according to witness
reports extracted from victims who were
taken to this little nightmare realm the
dimension resembles a series of twisting
endless corridors where the old man
stalks and tortures his captured victims
to the breaking point manipulating space
and time to his own sadistic ends on
rare occasions the scp will even release
its victims just for the joy of hunting
capturing and torturing them all over
again while agent resnick was learning
the true meaning of terror containment
specialists were mobilizing in itself
preparing the one known tried and true
method of luring the old man back
tempting it with the prospect of causing
even more suffering in order to do this
foundation personnel take one of the
aforementioned class d personnel and
begin inducing extreme pain by breaking
a major bone or slicing a tendon every
20 minutes the victim's agonizing
screams are then played over the
facility's intercom acting as bait for
the pain-loving old man the screams echo
through the facility's otherwise silent
halls as the mutilated corpse of agent
resnick falls from a new scorch mark on
the ceiling the old man can hear the
sounds of suffering ringing out through
the air around him and he can barely
contain his excitement over the prospect
of a new play thing the snapped femurs
the torn achilles tendons it was all too
good to miss having had its twisted fun
with the security officers and observers
scp-106 wandered back to its containment
cell where a new screaming victim
awaited the other security officers
containment specialists and scientists
evacuated the area leaving the old man
alone with his prey while the
unfortunate class d was left to his fate
the rest of the staff commenced cleanup
procedures which mainly involve wiping
the brown and black mucus from the walls
it would probably be at least another
month before anything like this happened
again and new personnel would be
transferred over to the facility to
replace the fallen all in all just
another night at the scp foundation
every time a bell rings an angel gets
its wings it's an iconic line from it's
a wonderful life and even if you don't
believe in angels it is a pleasant image
after all angels are the embodiment of
goodness and light so an angel getting
its wings has to be a good thing right
well as anyone who's ever eaten one too
many christmas cookies can tell you it's
possible to have too much of a good
thing even something that sounds like
the embodiment of all things good in
theory can become deadly when taken to
the extreme
that is where
scp-469 also known as the many-winged
angel comes in this angel-like creature
is anything but innocent and in fact it
has been responsible for multiple deaths
of scp foundation personnel during its
captivity
scp-469 may be deadly but it is also
undeniably beautiful in a mysterious
ethereal way when first seen it appears
to be nothing more than a massive pile
of pristine white feathers like
something out of a pillow commercial the
pile measures 24 feet in diameter and
weighs at least two tons however like
many of the entities contained within
the walls of the foundation's countless
containment sites all is not as it seems
with 469 what looks at first glance to
be a pile of feathers is in fact a dense
curled mass of giant wings the wings
vary in size from the tiny wingspan of a
sparrow to the staggering 3.6 meter
wingspan of the wandering albatross the
one thing they have in common is their
plumage with each wing being covered
with the same glossy white feathers the
foundation was able to perform a series
of x-rays on the mass of wings revealing
a skeletal structure beneath the
feathers like those of a bird the wing's
bones are hollow however they are
unnaturally soft and flexible allowing
for a range of motion that no known bird
possesses this accounts for the
curvature of the wings and their ability
to coil tightly into each other the
x-ray also provided the first and only
recorded glimpse at the creature hiding
underneath all the feathers at the
center of the layers upon layers of
wings is a humanoid creature curled into
a fetal position in defiance of the laws
of natural anatomy every single wing
appears to be fused to this creature's
spine how would it be able to move under
the weight of these wings or even if it
could is as of yet unknown the first
foundation personnel lost to scp-469
were d-class personnel d-112 and d-624
who were sent in to investigate the
nature of the creature and attempt to
contact the humanoid entity identified
on the x-rays 112 and 624 entered the
room equipped with gloves and protective
eye gear as scientists watched the
situation unfold on a monitor on a video
feed no one expected much to come of the
encounter the working hypothesis was the
layers of feathers would simply be too
thick to get through without seriously
damaging the bones it would be a fairly
uneventful experiment or so they thought
112 approached
scp-469 first and attempted to part a
section of its feathers with his hands
as 624 stood back and observed the
moment his fingertips touched the
feathers a rustling sound filled the
room the feathers began to quiver
shaking as if all waking up at once from
a deep slumber suddenly in the blink of
an eye the hundreds and hundreds of
wings unfurled and pulled one one two
into their depths he was swept into a
swirl of feathers and within seconds he
had disappeared from view completely
though 624 and the scientists watching
on their monitor could no longer see him
they could certainly hear him from the
moment the wings pulled him into the sea
of feathers one one two had begun to
scream in agony his screams persisted
growing louder and more desperate even
as the voice cracked and grew weak 624
stood frozen in place with fear and
shock 624 was ordered to attempt to
retrieve 112 from the feathers but made
no move to do so he simply stared at the
feathers eyes wide face pale as the pain
shrieks of his colleague bounced off the
sterile white walls of the containment
room a guard called over the intercom
threatening to terminate 624 if he did
not attempt to remove 112 from
scp-469's grasp this warning seemed to
shock 624 back into action and he made a
run for the center feathers arms up to
protect his face again the sound of
rustling as the feathers began to quake
the wings unfurled once more and 624 did
not even have a chance to turn back
before he was pulled in to meet the same
dismal fate as the other d-class his
screams of pain joined 1-1-2 as the
scientists watching over the monitor
could do nothing to help them as the two
men cried out in pain and horror from
within their winged prisons something
began to happen that the scientists had
never seen before the feathers started
to shake again faster than before and at
first the wings appeared to be unfolding
again upon second look though it was
clear they hadn't moved there were
simply more of them now as the men
continued to scream more feathers
appeared the wings stretching out and
elongating as new wings sprouted as if
from nowhere
scp-469 appeared to be feeding on the
sound of their screams and using that
energy to expand it was only after
several long minutes when the screaming
finally stopped that the growth of the
wings did too at this point the wings
shifted again expelling the bodies of
112 and 624 from within its folds
dropping them limply on the ground
though their deaths were unfortunate the
loss of 112 and 624 did reveal some new
information about scp-469
first that it could grow and apparently
needed to feed on sounds in order to do
so second that it was deadly to humans
and most likely to other living things
as well autopsies of one one two and six
two force corpses would later reveal
exactly what happened to them and how
scp-469 kills its prey though 469's
feathers may look as though they would
be soft to the touch each feather is
actually made up of sharp barbs that are
capable of piercing clothing and skin
these barbs release a neurotoxin into
the system that activates every pain
receptor in the body of the victim the
neurotoxin present in these feathers has
not been identified anywhere else in
nature but is somewhat similar in
structure and function to the
neurotoxins excreted by the cone snail
and in the bite of the blue ringed
octopus in addition to the pain-inducing
neurotoxin the feathers also carry
several unidentified stimulant compounds
where the neurotoxin on its own would
induce enough pain for the affected
party to pass out almost immediately the
stimulants serve to keep the victim
conscious scp foundation scientists
posit that this is so that 469 can get
as much noise in this case in the form
of screams out of its pain as possible
and achieve maximum growth before the
captive creature dies or goes into shock
further experiments confirm this theory
and show that
scp-469 will react similarly when
exposed to any living creature capable
of making a sound and experiencing pain
not just humans non-living matter though
including dead animals elicit no
response from 469. additional
experiments were then undertaken that
involved applying various different
sounds in order to test their effect on
scp-469's growth though it feeds on any
sounds produced in its presence it seems
to respond most strongly to musical
sounds exhibiting a particularly strong
response to classical music no sound
elicits a stronger reaction from this
creature however than the sound of
ringing bells it is rumored that when a
bell was wrong in the presence of 469
the humanoid at the center of the
feathers is said to have moved for the
first time on record apparently whatever
is at the center appeared to wake up and
unfurl its wings revealing itself but
unfortunately all security footage of
this incident has been white and the
data has been expunged from the record
leaving the creature's true form a
mystery you may be remembering that four
members of foundation personnel on
record were lost to scp-469
and that only two have been mentioned so
far the second pair of casualties
resulted when the foundation attempted
to terminate
scp-469 believing that there was no more
scientific benefit to keeping it alive
or at least that the possible benefits
did not outweigh the risks it was
ordered that scp-469 be terminated by
any means necessary two skilled
personnel dr jones and dr smith were
sent into the containment facility in
hazmat gear armed with several sharp
instruments they were to attempt to use
these to cut through the forest of
feathers and soft bones until they could
reach the humanoid at the center it was
presumed that once they did and the
creature no longer had the protection of
its poisonous feathers that it would be
relatively easy to kill they could not
have been more wrong dr jones approached
the dense cover of feathers with a pair
of sharpened gardening shears while dr
smith opted for a machete at first the
strategy appeared to be working dr jones
made several quick cuts with feathers
fluttering to the floor and sticking to
the hazmat suit as dr smith slashed into
the feathers with his machete making
similarly promising progress however the
situation quickly took a turn for the
worse when dr jones dropped her sheers
and let out a blood-curdling scream the
feathers had taken a little longer to
get through the suit to her skin but
somehow they managed to find a way just
the same smith grabbed jones and
attempted to make a break for it but he
was too slow and far too close to the
feathers already the wings wrapped
around them and swallowed them both up
leaving the researchers outside helpless
to do anything but listen to their
screams and wait for them to go quiet
after several minutes they finally did
and now larger
scp-469 had officially claimed another
two foundation personnel obviously 469
could not be terminated using any
methods that would place the responsible
personnel within its grasp that was
simply too risky so the foundation
selected a team of d-class personnel to
attempt to burn the feathers with an
array of flamethrowers though the
feathers were vulnerable to fire and
began to blacken and disintegrate on
contact the sound of the flames being
expelled was loud enough to feed
scp-469 its growth was so quick in
response to the noise that the fire
could not keep up with the amount of new
feathers and wings being produced by the
same time the flamethrowers ran out of
propellant 469 was the same size it had
been when they started other
terminations have been discussed
including the possibility of submerging
the entire creature in a highly
corrosive acid but so far this has not
yet been attempted whatever they end up
trying it is clear that nothing that
produces a significant amount of noise
will be able to kill 469 so where is it
now what's become of this perverse angel
with the never-ending wings currently it
is kept in an airtight soundproof
chamber where nothing can trigger the
growth of any more wings so
what is it an angel a demon a twisted
mutated bird of some kind it is entirely
possible that we will never know but
it's a wonderful life had something
right even by accident every time a bell
rings something twisted and deadly
though it may be
gets its wings
when an anomaly is first detected by an
scp foundation field agent it's up to
the foundation's mobile task forces to
tag and bag the impossible entities
before they can do any more harm
sometimes these retrievals are
uneventful other times
not so much
especially when they're dealing with
brutal forces of nature like scp-096
also known as the shy guy a creature
that from the very first interaction
with the foundation
had a reputation for being dangerous and
needed to be feared
a series of vague sightings and
mysterious disappearances up in the
frosty mountains of the yukon first
sparked the foundation's interest when
they were certain that they had an
anomaly on their hands two retrieval
teams zulu9a and zulu9b were dispatched
to secure and contain the entity
zulu9a took the lead in a heavy duty
chopper equipped with 50 caliber gau-19
heavy machine guns and carrying an at4
anti-tank launcher they were prepared
for anything or so they thought as they
established a visual on
scp-096 while two clicks away from the
target they couldn't get a clear line of
sight on the creature but it appeared to
be stationary docile and was making no
attempt to flay a piece of cake right
little did they know that
scp-096 was just looking away from them
if it was facing towards them it'd be a
whole different horror story as zulu9a
were about to find out the team landed
their helicopter next to the creature
and were shocked to see that it was
completely naked in spite of the subzero
temperatures all around them the
creature was unnaturally thin as though
it had been starved for weeks with bone
white skin and unnaturally long lips the
team guessed that the creature's arms
must have been at least 1.5 meters long
but its docile nature and insubstantial
body mass gave the impression that it
wouldn't prove too difficult to contain
that is
until they saw its face
zulu 9a's captain was the lone survivor
of the incident as he was lucky enough
to be looking away when the creature
turned towards his team the rest of the
squad ended up staring eye to eye with
scp-096
and from that moment on wasn't docile
anymore the creature began to whimper
then cry then sob uncontrollably in a
way that sounded eerily human this
sudden change in temperament startled
the rest of zulu 9a and they opened fire
on the creature under the hail of
gunfire
scp-096 entered a murderous frenzy and
began tearing into the hapless squad of
soldiers while its flesh and organs did
seem to take damage as a result of the
barrage of 50 caliber rounds from the
helicopter mounted machine guns
its skeletal structure remained intact
and it continued its onslaught tearing
the team limb from limb even after they
blown practically all the flesh from the
creature
the at4 anti-tank launcher proved
equally ineffective at stopping scp-096
while it was in attack mode it was only
after slaughtering the entire team that
it returned to its docile state nobody
knows exactly what the creature did to
zulu 9a after the gunfire started but no
trace of the team was left behind
zulu 9b touched down soon after and with
a grave warning from the captain not to
look at the creature's face they were
finally able to subdue it a bag was
placed over scp-096's face which seemed
to soothe it enough to move it to a
nearby foundation facility little did
they know they just obtained one of the
deadliest scps of all time and while it
may have been under lock and key for now
it seemed inevitable that it would get
out and cause more violence and chaos
research and containment procedures for
the scp-096 were put under the command
of dr dan a senior researcher at the
site it was his job to find out exactly
what this being was capable of the more
he tested the more he realized that they
were dealing with something truly
terrifying disposable d-class personnel
were used to figure out exactly what it
was that caused the creature to enter
its attack mode
just as it had during the initial
retrieval mission
scp-096 went berserk when any of the
attending personnel saw its face in this
stage it would enter a period of
considerable and unstoppable distress
for one to two minutes covering its face
and wailing loudly when the period of
distress ended the creature would
mercilessly slaughter every d-class that
had seen its face and just like with
zulu9a no trace of their bodies would be
left behind
dr den was horrified and intrigued by
this phenomenon the creature killed
anyone that saw its face directly but
could the same be said for indirect
depictions of the creature's face
such as images and videos
dr dan was desperate to find out more
d-class personnel were brought in to
test this to frightening results dr dan
found that the creature did indeed still
enter attack mode when people saw
pictures and videos of
scp-096's face the creature seemed to
have an innate sense of when people were
viewing these representations even when
it should have had no conceivable way of
knowing it didn't matter how far away or
how many barriers were in place between
the viewer and the creature the attack
mode would still activate and once it
did it seemed as though nothing could
stop the creature from hunting down the
one who saw its face with all this new
data special containment procedures were
devised to keep the creature safely
under lock and key its cell was a five
meter by five meter by five meter
airtight steel cube
fitted with advanced pressure sensors
and laser detectors to ensure that
scp-096 remained in itself without
risking anyone having visual contact
with the creature's face all cameras and
video equipment were strictly forbidden
and weekly checks for any cracks or
holes in the containment cell were
mandatory
of course none of this would stop the
creature if anyone somehow saw its face
in order to solve that little problem dr
dan would need to continue his research
to find a method of subverting the
creature's deadly glance they needed to
know exactly what they were dealing with
but how could they when even a glance at
a photo or video of the being meant
certain death
a potential solution was proposed
creating an artistic representation of
the creature's face something that
hadn't yet been attempted but how would
they achieve such a fee simple they'd
procure a d-class prisoner with some
artistic talent
and they found one who had been a tattoo
artist before becoming a foundation
guinea pig
dr dan formulated an ingenious plan for
keeping this d-class alive for long
enough to accurately draw an image of
scp-096's face
he would be placed in a bathysphere
diving bell several kilometers
underwater and tens of kilometers away
from the containment cell where the scp
was being held the d-class was made to
look at a photograph of the creature's
face and then replicate that image in a
pencil sketch
dr dan first confirmed that the
creature's attack mode is only activated
by the creature's face by having the
d-class look at a series of photos of
the scp's body parts one by one finally
finishing with its face the d-class
began drawing and even remarked on how
creepy the scp's facial features were
despite not knowing the deadly context
meanwhile back in its containment cell
scp-096 sensed someone viewing its face
and entered its inconsolable crying
state followed by its attack mode it
broke out of containment easily and
began making a beeline for the d-class
traversing the miles between it and its
prey the d-class didn't know it as he
locked the finished drawing into a
separate autonomous submersible but he
was already dead
as the drawing made its way up to a
researcher on the surface
scp-096 dived into the water and started
swimming down towards the artist minutes
later the bathysphere was breached
and the d-class was torn to shreds
scp-096 was recaptured without issue by
surface recovery team foxtrot 303-a
and further testing on the drawing
showed that artistic representations of
scp-096's face were in fact harmless
from this experience we now know that
the creature has a gaunt face with
totally white eyes possibly indicating
blindness and a grossly extended jaw
nevertheless dr dan was adamant that
scp-096 was too dangerous to be left
alive and requested permission from the
upper echelons of the foundation to
terminate the creature by any means
necessary however the doctor's request
would fall on deaf ears
until
it all started with a seemingly innocent
image
while it's now been redacted for your
safety the black speck inside the yellow
circle was once a minuscule image of
scp-096 taken unknowingly in the 1990s
by a semi-professional mountaineer one
day they were looking at old photographs
when his eyes passed over the tiny speck
without even noticing that he had seen
anything but scp-096 noticed and began
entering its attack mode it tore through
its steel containment unit like tissue
paper causing the release of a nerve
agent that killed a number of attending
foundation staff the monster then fled
the base and began pursuing its prey
with mobile task force tau 1 in hot
pursuit
dr olixi who is helping to manage the
site where the scp was contained was in
dismay over the situation dr dan was out
of the country at the time trying to
discover more about the creature's
origins however he did leave the mobile
task force with a new secret weapon
against the rampaging shy guy
project scramble scramble were
state-of-the-art goggles featuring a new
technology created by dr dan which using
artistic renditions of 096's facial
features could detect and scramble the
features of scp-096 into an
unrecognizable form preventing the
normally deadly effect of gazing upon
its face
in theory this would allow mtf tau1 to
engage safely with 096 once its prey had
been eliminated and bring it back into
containment but disaster struck on two
fronts first the prey in question was
located in a population center creating
the potential for a huge loss of life
and the second bigger problem was that
the scramble technology didn't work as
stray pixels of the creature's face
would reach the eyes of the task force
before the internal microprocessor had
time to scramble them the mission turned
into a death sentence as scp-096
slaughtered almost the entire task force
as well as a number of civilians in town
including an infant and its entire
family it was a monumental disaster made
even worse by a final revelation dr dan
and dr alexey had themselves facilitated
the entire containment breach and
allowed the resulting massacre to happen
with dr dan hoping it would be enough
motivation for foundation command to
green light his research into destroying
the creature
anything that would give him the
opportunity to kill this thing would be
worth the bloodshed his plan worked and
the scp foundation saw it his way
approving his request to neutralize
scp-096
however success comes at a cost for dr
dan once he figures out a way to finally
kill the creature though done in his
line of duty he himself will be
terminated by the foundation for his
crimes against humanity
but considering how much damage scp-096
is capable of causing if it ever got to
a major population center or even worse
was ever caught on camera and broadcast
to a worldwide audience the doctor
himself would likely deem his own death
a justifiable cause
to this day the foundation is
researching ways to kill the creature
and they're still looking for their
silver bullet
and the pressure is on they hadn't known
about the seemingly innocent picture
that sparked the last containment breach
the one taken decades ago in which the
shy guy had only occupied four tiny
pixels four tiny pixels that resulted in
multiple innocent lives lost
so be careful where you look because who
knows how many other photos of the
creature are lurking out there photos
with an innocent dot in the background
your eyes glance over it not even
noticing the little blip
until you hear a distant wailing that
seems to be getting closer and closer
and closer
and then
it's already too late
you